vous avez les Rolls-Royce on dit ça
comme les autres sont pas là de la
délégation qui sont arrivés
voilà merci à l'équipe d'ailleurs qui
prépare la salle et qui arrive vraiment
très très à l'heure du coup puisque vous
le voyez les sénatrices et où sénateurs
puisqu'il y a des sénateurs dans la
délégation arrivent juste à l'heure
voilà donc chers collègues mesdames et
messieurs nous poursuivons ce matin nos
travaux sur la thématique santé des
femmes au travail avec quatre apporteurs
donc Laurence Cohen qui va probablement
nous rejoindre Annick jacquemey qui est
présente avec nous ce matin Marie-Pierre
Richer également et Laurence Rossignol
qui n'avait pas dit qu'elle sera absente
je pense qu'elle va nous rejoindre
également et donc notre collègue
Marie-Pierre Monnier qui est la
gentillesse d'être là ce matin aussi à
nos côtés
lors de nos précédentes auditions nous
avons pu dresser trois principaux
constats premièrement la santé des
femmes au travail si elle a fait l'objet
de recherche en sciences sociales a été
peu étudié sous l'angle des politiques
de santé publique et les spécificités
des femmes en matière de santé hors du
champ de la santé sexuelle et productive
manque trop souvent de visibilité
j'en profite pour saluer madame qui est
en visio également
deuxièmement les femmes sont de plus en
plus exposées au risque professionnel
accidents du travail et maladie
professionnelle mais cette exposition
est sous-estimée notamment dans les
secteurs du Caire de la grande
distribution et de l'entretien ce qui ne
conduira à faire des focus sur ces
secteurs prédominance féminine les
femmes représentent 58% des cas de
troubles musculo-squelettiques les TMS
et elles sont les premières victimes des
risques psychosociaux les cancers
professionnels chez les femmes sont
également sous-évaluées alors même que
pour ne prendre qu'un exemple le travail
de nuit augmente de 26% le risque du
cancer du sein troisièmement les
politiques de prévention tiennent
insuffisamment compte des risques
professionnels particuliers auxquels les
femmes sont exposées bonjour Laurence
Cohen rapporte également sur ce sujet
l'objet de notre table ronde chacun est
de recueillir l'analyse de
professionnelle de santé sur ces
problématiques ainsi que leur
recommandations en vue de mieux intégrer
les questions de santé des femmes au
sein des actions de prévention et de
santé au travail et de la formation bien
entendu des médecins du travail à cette
fin nous avons cueillons Anne Michel
Chartier présidente du Syndicat général
des médecins et des professionnels
émotionnels des services de santé au
travail
Magalie Chevassus
psychologue du travail à la ismt 13
l'association interprofessionnelle de
santé et de médecine du travail réseau
Présence JE N'AI PAS écorché votre nom
madame tout va bien Carole Donnay
secrétaire général de l'Association des
médecins responsables de services
nationaux de médecine du travail
d'entreprise la commodet comme on dit
je n'aime pas trop les acronymes donc
souvent je la fais un blocage dessus
Alice de Maximy fondatrice du collectif
femme de santé
Laetitia Rollin maître de conférence
universitaire praticien hospitalier au
sein du service Santé au Travail et
pathologies professionnelle du CHU de
Rouen qui est connecté en visio avec
nous bienvenue madame donc je vous
souhaite à vous toutes en visio et en
présentiel la bienvenue peut-être
pourrait vous expliquer les raisons
selon vous pour lesquelles les risques
et maladies professionnelles associées
au poste occupé par les femmes sont
encore aujourd'hui insuffisamment
identifiés et reconnu quelle mesure
pourrait-on prendre pourrait-on mettre
en place pour mieux d'augmenter
répertoriés et prendre en compte ces
risques et maladies professionnelles
spécifiques comment les médecins et
psychologues du travail abordent-ils
aujourd'hui les questions de santé de
travailleuses sous le prisme du genre
sont-ils réellement formés à cela
quelle adaptation des postes de travail
êtes-vous amené le cas échéant à
proposer aux salariés atteintes de
problèmes de santé notamment
l'endométriose le cancer du sein et
évidemment d'autres maladies que je ne
cite pas ce matin afin de leur permettre
de se maintenir dans leur emploi dans
les meilleures conditions nous nous
intéressons également aux conséquences
pour la santé physique et mentale des
femmes des récentes transformation du
marché du travail évidemment je pense au
télétravail par exemple
enfin nous avons décidé de privilégier
une approche par métier en nous
focalisant sur certaines filières
notamment
féminisées telles que le Caire et les
services et soins à la personne la
grande distribution le nettoyage et le
travail dit domestique ou encore le
mannequinat et les métiers de tests
d'accueil par exemple des études
spécifiques sur la santé des
travailleuses de ces filières
existent-elles comment les conditions
dans lesquelles les femmes exercent les
métiers affectent-elles leur santé
des politiques particulières de
prévention en matière de santé au
travail existe-t-elle dans ces filières
pour répondre à ces différentes
questions je laisse sans plus tarder la
parole d'abord à Carole de nez
secrétaire général de la commode
la comète
la commode la commode
bon à la fin de la réunion ça se passe
ça ira je serai Calais je pense la
comède voilà madame donnait c'est mieux
voilà maintenant à vous la parole madame
donnez merci madame la Présidente merci
mesdames les rapporteurs donc je me fais
ici le porte-parole de l'association
akomed donc qui est l'Association
française des médecins responsables
nationaux de grandes entreprises et qui
sont en charge de la coordination des
services de prévention et de santé au
travail dit autonome en notre collectif
représente les médecins d'une trentaine
de grands groupes du CAC 40 dans des
domaines d'activités variés tels que
l'industrie de pointe aéronautique
aérospatiale industrie métallurgique et
sidérurgique
l'agroalimentaire le secteur du
transport le secteur assurantiel et
bancaire le secteur de l'énergie
l'industrie pharmaceutique et cosmétique
et le secteur de la construction et
service postal
alors je tiens à vous souligner tout de
même que nous n'avons pas de
représentants dans notre collectif de
médecin
coordinateur national d'entreprise de
représentants du secteur de soins ou du
nettoyage ou de la grande distribution
cependant certaines de nos entreprises
interviennent pour ou dans ces secteurs
d'activité ou font intervenir
dans le cadre de la sous-traitance les
salariés de ces secteurs
dans notre rôle en tant que médecin du
travail consiste à éviter toute
altération de la santé des travailleurs
du fait de leur travail ça c'est le code
du travail et pour cela nous conseillons
l'employeur sur l'évaluation la
suppression la réduction des risques
professionnels pour un ensemble de
salariés exposés
actuellement les actions de prévention
collective sont entreprises par les
employeurs et s'applique généralement à
tout un collectif de travail
elles ont pour objectif de supprimer ou
de réduire le risque en se référant des
valeurs limites d'exposition ou à des
normes qui prennent pas en compte
d'éventuelles spécificités de genre mais
pas non plus de handicap mais pas non
plus des conditions d'âge
c'est spécificités de genre d'ajout de
handicap sont par contre prises en
considération à titre individuel et ce
par le médecin du travail lors des
visites médicales en santé au travail et
où le médecin du travail évalue s'il
exposition professionnelle résiduelle du
salarié peuvent avoir ou pas un impact
sur l'état de santé du salarié en
fonction du coût de ses caractéristiques
et selon cette évaluation il peut donc
prescrire des mesures prévention
individuelles donc par exemple un port
d'équipements de protection individuel
par exemple ou alors il peut aussi
prescrire des aménagements de poste qui
permettra de d'extraire le salarié du
risque ou de réduire l'exposition du
salarié au risque
donc en entreprise à caractérisation
l'évaluation des risques professionnels
des postes occupés par les femmes sont
probablement connus de tous au même
titre que ceux des hommes ils sont
évalués de la même façon en fait il n'y
a pas de spécificité de genre certaines
expositions sont même
connus pour être spécifiquement à risque
pour les femmes donc c'est le cas du
travail de nuit vous l'avez souligné ou
le risque de cancer du sein chez la
femme est un risque identifié pour
lequel la surveillance du risque a fait
l'objet d'une recommandation de bonnes
pratiques qui a été labellisée en 2012
par la chasse et c'est à peu près le
seul chose que
qui est un peu spécifique
il semble en revanche que les risques
professionnels dans les secteurs
professionnels plutôt féminin ne soit
pas suffisamment maîtrisé au regard de
certains secteurs plutôt masculins vous
avez cité nettoyage c'est plutôt un
secteur très féminin
de même les spécificités liées au fait
que le poste soit occupé par une femme
sont pas suffisamment perçus sauf dans
le cas précis de l'état de grossesse ou
de l'allaitement ou le lien entre santé
exposition professionnelle chez la femme
alerte presque systématiquement les
employeurs et donc les visites chez les
médecins du travail sont souvent
déclenchés donc soit par l'employeur
soit par la salarié elle-même qui dans
cet état là on va dire va se signaler
et non dans ces cas là des aménagements
de poste sont en généralement
préconisés et sont généralement non plus
pas contester ce qui est un peu
important
par contre il y a pas suffisamment c'est
vrai une prise de conscience de
spécificités telles que les spécificités
anthropométriques ou physiologiques des
femmes dans la conception par exemple
des postes de travail
aujourd'hui il passe du travail peuvent
être occupé aussi bien par des hommes et
par des femmes
et cependant voilà les les conditions
dans lequel on crée aujourd'hui les
postes sont souvent normés du coup sur
des sur des des mesures masculines et
donc ça ça peut générer par contre des
maladies professionnelles par exemple en
milieu de production la conception de
lignes de montage ou de production
prennent pour référence entre pays
métriques des mesures masculines ainsi
les postes de travail sont souvent en
plus non réglables donc elles sont peu
adaptées au gabarit des femmes et ça
c'est un risque d'apparition de TMS par
exemple
autre exemple dans la logistique
exposant en port de charge et où le
travail se féminise de plus en plus
l'organisation du travail et la
conception de des postes ne prévoit pas
de rendre tous les postes accessibles
aux femmes en s'adaptant à la différence
du corps des femmes par rapport à celle
des hommes donc une taille plus petite
une force musculaire plus faible un
centre de gravité plus bas des un poids
moindres un débit cardiaque inférieur
ainsi les femmes en logistique sont
souvent reliées à des postes on va dire
de premier échelon à forte manipulation
manuelle donc du picking du copaking de
l'emballage elles sont souvent moins
productives ou en limite physique
lorsqu'elle les occupe des postes
d'imasculins et donc ça perturbe aussi
leurs évolutions de carrière qui sont
limitées et moins rapide que les hommes
et ça les expose on va dire d'autant
plus aux risques de TMS notamment
puisque moi on peut évoluer dans le
milieu de la logistique et puis on
exposé au risque
alors on constate aussi qu'au fil des
années l'organisation de la prévention
des risques professionnels dans le
secteur professionnel plutôt féminin ne
soit pas la hauteur des actions qui ont
pu être engagées dans des secteurs
d'activité plutôt masculins perçues
comme plus pénible comme le BTP par
exemple en effet le risque accidentogène
et une maladie professionnelle grave
engageant le pronostic vital comme
exposition à l'amiante à la silice dans
des activités très masculines ont plutôt
attiré le regard de toutes les autorités
de contrôle et ont poussé du coup les
entreprises à s’engager dans de la
prévention et dans la maîtrise de ces
risques professionnels en comparaison
les risques professionnels du secteur
ducaire ou du nettoyage ont pu être
banalisés dans leur appréciation par les
employeurs et par les salariés eux-mêmes
au regard de ce qui a été fait tout chez
ces secteurs là
particulièrement aussi on peut souligner
que dans ces secteurs l'organisation
préventive donc le repérage l'analyse de
risque et la prévention a eu du mal à se
mettre en place faute de moyens
notamment dans la fonction publique
hospitalière au regard de ce qui peut
être fait dans le privé
et dans le secteur du nettoyage même si
des actions ont été menées par la
branche depuis ces dernières années pour
améliorer la prévention il reste encore
bien des choses à faire du point de vue
de la formation du personnel qui souvent
maîtrise pas très bien le français on
des recours de soins qui sont plutôt
parsemés d'embûches et qui ne
connaissent pas leurs droits en matière
de déclaration maladie professionnelle
ce qui peut expliquer aussi des formes
de sous de déclaration
au final la connaissance et la maîtrise
des risques professionnels ne fait pas
toujours l'objet d'une différence
d'évaluation selon le genre mais c'est
peut-être à tort et on peut légitimement
s'interroger de l'intérêt de le faire
notamment au regard des statistiques de
maladies professionnelles chez les
femmes que vous avez soulignées et
notamment dans certains secteurs et pour
mieux documenter et pour mieux prendre
en compte les risques professionnels
chez femmes au regard de leur
spécificité
il me semble qu'une étude statistique de
corps national permettrait des analyses
plus poussées statistiques passe secteur
d'activité par exposition aux risques et
ça serait certainement une bonne
proposition à vous faire pour
sensibiliser pour mettre aussi en place
des actions qui pourraient faire l'objet
d'une priorité d'action ensuite dans de
cadre de politiques plus globale tels
que les plans sentaient travail en terme
de politique santé en termes de
politique de santé au travail ou alors
au niveau de politique de santé publique
malheureusement aujourd'hui on sentait
au travail on va dire l'espacement des
visites médicales faites par les
médecins et le fait que certaines de ces
visites médicales
ne soient plus réalisé par les médecins
mais aussi par des médecins traitants
dans des secteurs très féminisés comme
le service à la personne ou le
mannequinat ça nous permet plus
tellement d'avoir on va dire une vision
exhaustive une vision globale de la
situation des femmes au travail
donc d'où le recours du coup à une étude
statistique nationale et plus globale
qui qui serait fait peut-être par par
santé publique France ou autre de façon
à pouvoir du coup analyser un petit peu
mieux ce qui se passe ou par un
laboratoire de recherche type pinson
ce qu'on peut aussi préconiser pour
mieux connaître le
l'étude du travail des femmes ce serait
des études ergonomiques qui seraient
centrées sur l'analyse des activités du
travail des femmes et qui permettrait
également de mettre en évidence la
nécessité de réviser certains
référentiels de conception de poste par
exemple de travail afin qu'ils soient
bien adapté
autant aux hommes qu'aux femmes que
l'évaluation des risques professionnels
[Musique]
n'est pas genre à l'exception du travail
de nuit et
du risque de cancer du sein comme je
vous les ai dit mais sur la base de
données scientifiques qui pourraient
venir dans certaines activités ce serait
certainement pertinent d'inclure la
dimension du genre au sein du document
unique d'évaluation des risques et le
document de référence du coup de
l'évaluation des risques professionnels
en entreprise
enfin les campagnes de sensibilisation
ciblées auprès des femmes permettraient
aussi de mieux les informer des risques
spécifiques encourus au travail mais
aussi de les inviter à mieux repérer et
à mieux consulter
lors des premiers symptômes évoquant des
pathologies professionnelles et aussi ça
pourrait limiter le risque de sous
déclaration que l'on peut légitimement
suspecter
donc la façon dont le médecin du travail
à bord de la question de la santé des
travailleurs sur le prisme du genre et
tout d'abord en visite médicale lors de
l'évaluation de l'équilibre du lien
entre la santé et le travail et dans la
dimension santé on retrouve les aspects
de santé physique mentale et sociales et
prix à leur rencontre notamment des
spécificités anthropométriques de la
personne et l'adaptation de son poste
mais aussi la charge mentale en lien
avec le travail mais aussi avec la vie
sociale la vie familiale
la situation familiale
les salariés aidants et la capacité de
la salarié à préserver du coup des temps
de répit ou de déconnexion et des temps
d'activités loisirs notamment extra
professionnelle comme de l'activité
physique par exemple en cas de
déséquilibre des aménagements en cas
déséquilibre du coup de du lien santé
travail des aménagements de poste seront
donc proposés plus récemment les
médecins du travail s'investissent aussi
de plus en plus dans des actions de
prévention de santé publique et peuvent
être en relais de campagne de santé de
campagne de santé publique nationale
consacrer notamment des pistaches des
cancers notamment cancers du sein chez
la femme
lors des manifestations Adobe rose qui
sont très largement maintenant relayés
en entreprise
les aménagements de poste permettant
l'équipe du lien santé travail chez la
femme et le maintient en emploi sont
diverses et vont aussi dépendre du type
de poste de la personne et de sa
problématique on peut envisager des
réductions du temps de travail sous la
forme du mi-temps thérapeutique ou alors
du télétrail dans le secteur tertiaires
pour les secteurs non tertiaires le
télétravail n'est pas possible donc on
peut envisager des réductions de temps
de travail des pauses plus fréquentes
des réductions de certaines tâches
physiques ou des postes avec de moins de
contraintes productives et moins de
pression temporelle et aussi penser à
des évictions de poste dans le cas d'un
risque d'exposition un des cancérogènes
mutagènes et reprotoxiques notamment sur
les femmes en âge de procréer
les aménagements sur le long terme
notamment lorsqu'il faut gérer
beaucoup d'événements d'absentéisme peut
poser parfois des problèmes de maintien
en emploi et on le constate
effectivement pour des formes assez
importantes de d'endométriose ou de
syndrome des ovaires polykystiques ou
alors dans des longs parcours de PMA
pour les cancers du sein nous n'avons
pas d'accompagnement différencier en
fait nous accompagnons nos salariés au
retour à l'emploi comme on le ferait
pour n'importe quel cancer mais il est
vrai que dans le cancer du sein plus
spécifiquement nous avons plus accès et
recours à des structurations
associatives externes qui sont
spécialisées dans ce type de cancer et
qui nous aide bien du coup à réintégrer
les personnes en entreprise et à
reprendre la confiance en soi au sein de
l'entreprise
et dans l'emploi
alors vous posiez la question des
transformations des organisations de
travail pandémique covid on constate
aussi effectivement une généralisation
des activités de télétravail qui sont en
général de l'ordre de 1 à 2 jours par
semaine en entreprise elle se régule
autour de ce vers là les nouvelles ces
nouvelles organisations du travail en
mode du bride sont plutôt plébiscitées
par les femmes dans nos expériences car
ça permet une meilleure conciliation de
la vie professionnelle et de la vie
personnelle et ça permet aussi des
économies de fatigue liée au transport
dans certaines régions
il est vrai qu'en pratique nous
constatons que les femmes ont des
charges et des responsabilités plus
familiales plus importantes que les
hommes notamment cas de séparation elles
ont souvent la garde des enfants toutes
les semaines de travail ces
responsabilités viennent parfois rendre
le véhicule du travail plus complexe
avec des ressources personnelles qui
sont affaiblies par la fatigue le manque
de temps de répit et le manque
d'activité sportif et d'activité loisirs
ceux-ci peut expliquer des augmentations
de troubles musculo-squelettiques
notamment dans milieu industriels ou des
risques de burn-out chez les femmes car
ce mélange dans la genèse de ces
pathologies ou de ce syndrome des
composantes de risque professionnels qui
viennent se sur Ajouter à des facteurs
de vie personnelle qui engendre déjà du
stress et de la charge mentale et ceci
prédispose à la maladie
ce sont des facteurs que nous prenons en
compte dans nos consultations de santé
au travail et qui nous amènent à prendre
des mesures sur le travail et orienter
les personnes aussi vers des personnes
ressources telles que les psychologues
et les assistantes sociales qui nous
accompagnent dans nos services
les femmes accèdent aussi de plus en
plus dans le cadre des politiques
d'égalité homme-femme à des postes à de
fortes responsabilités sans toujours une
égalité de moyens mis à disposition où
elle doit toujours faire leurs preuves
et elles n'ont pas non plus des
évolutions de carrière similaires se
pose aussi la question du risque de
Burnout dans ces situations parce qu'il
est difficile d'équilibrer sa présence
entre le travail et la vie personnelle
le choix et la renonciation sont souvent
admis au quotidien dans l'esprit des
femmes
quand tout va bien c'est de se faire
quand tout va bien dans les deux sphères
personnelles et professionnelles ça va
bien mais il suffit qu'une de ces
sphères se dégradent pour engendrer très
rapidement
des phénomènes de décompensation avec de
la frustration de l'anxiété et glisser
très rapidement dans des syndromes de
Burn Out ou d'anxiété dépression
pardon merci beaucoup madame la
secrétaire général de la comède
vous voyez je me suis entraîné pendant
toute votre intervention
je vous remercie pour ce premier
présentation et je vais laisser la
parole à Madame
Laetitia Rollin du service de santé au
travail et pathologies professionnelle
du CHU de Rouen qui avec nous en
visio-conférence vous êtes également
maître de conférences en médecine du
travail donc vous allez pouvoir
notamment évoquer avec nous la question
de la prise en compte des problématiques
de genre dans la formation des médecins
du travail à vous madame
merci beaucoup bonjour à tous merci
beaucoup de m'avoir invité à participer
ce matin à cette table ronde sur la
santé des au travail des femmes alors
j'ai choisi de vous parler ce matin de
quelques exemples seulement du quotidien
de ce qu'on peut voir en français au
travail
sous l'angle de la vision sous l'angle
des femmes j'ai choisi de présenter vous
avez juste pardon madame au niveau du
micro vous utilisez quel micro parce
qu'il y a quelques grésillements alors
peut-être qu'il faut juste modifier
est-ce que c'est mieux là j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a moins de
graissiements dans votre voix mais on va
voir on va le voir sur la durée voilà
merci
donc j'ai choisi de d'illustrer mon topo
en trois parties tout d'abord la santé
au travail des femmes deuxièmement le
maintien en emploi des femmes en prenant
l'exemple du cancer qui a été très
étudié ces dernières années et puis une
petite partie sur la protection de
l'enfant Annette alors sur la première
partie concernant la santé au travail
des femmes dans notre quotidien nous
sommes amenés à faire des consultations
des salariés et il existe un
observatoire qu'on appelle
l'Observatoire Everest évolution et
relation en santé au travail dont
l'objectif est de rendre des
statistiques collectives sur ces
consultations qui sont faites à la fois
par les médecins du travail et les
infirmiers de santé au travail et voyez
les résultats de la j'ai pris les
résultats de la Normandie puisqu'on
avait fait une lettre spécifique sur la
voilà les conditions de travail et la
santé des femmes sur la période
2017-2019 en Normandie où on avait
étudié près de 3000 salariés
et donc le jour de la consultation ou
dans les 7 jours précédents cette
consultation les troubles
musculo-squelettiques sont présentés ici
vous avez en plus clair les femmes et en
plus foncer les hommes et vous voyez les
écarts systématiques qui existent entre
les plaintes et signes cliniques du
rachis du membre supérieur ou du membre
inférieur où vous voyez systématiquement
les femmes qui sont au dessus et en
termes de plaint toute signes clinique
au-dessus des hommes vous avez
exactement la même chose pour les
troubles neuropsychiques avec des écarts
parfois plus importants sur la lassitude
la fatigue etc
donc premier constat plus de voilà de
difficultés de santé en général chez les
femmes par rapport aux hommes ce qu'on
constate également c'est que par exemple
les troubles musculo-squelettiques on
sait qu'on dépiste souvent plutôt chez
les femmes c'est troubles
musculo-squelettiques alors que pour les
hommes lorsqu'on fait le diagnostic
d'une pathologie elle est souvent à un
stade beaucoup plus avancé alors les
hypothèses d'explication sont multiples
et les collègues qui travaillent sur ces
hypothèses d'explications en mettent
plusieurs les plaintes sont peut-être
différentes peut-être une femme va
présenter plus de symptômes plutôt et
vallées verbaliser plus tôt ça peut être
une explication on l'a dit tout à
l'heure peut-être des prédispositions
différentes en termes de musculature etc
mais aussi probablement des expositions
au travail qui sont là aussi différentes
je continuerai par
toujours avec cette observatoire cette
même étude qui qui présente les
expositions des salariés là aussi de
leur vision de ce qui peut transparaître
lors des consultations et vous voyez là
aussi un écart entre les femmes et les
hommes et par exemple le bruit supérieur
à 80 décibels on voit un écart assez
naître entre les femmes qui sont à 11,9%
et 51% des hommes qui s'estiment exposés
au bruit ça c'est important pour nous en
santé au travail parce que lorsqu'on
mène des actions collectives de
prévention par exemple si on choisit un
thème je prends au hasard le thème du
bruit si on décide de dans un service de
santé au travail de s'intéresser au
bruit et de faire de la prévention sur
ce thème et bien il faut savoir qu'on
touchera probablement beaucoup plus les
hommes que les femmes si on choisit ça
donc c'est à prendre en compte lors de
nos de nos choix de prévention
thématiques etc
je poursuivrai sur cette question du
travail de nuit donc on parle dont on
parle souvent le Centre international de
recherche contre le cancer a bien sûr
classé le travail de nuit posté dans le
groupe 2A c'est-à-dire probablement
cancérogènes on parle souvent du cancer
du sein mais les études récentes
montrent que probablement il y a aussi
d'autres
d'autres cancers qui sont peuvent être
favorisés par ce travail de nuit donc
notamment le cancer de la prostate il y
a beaucoup d'études là dessus le cancer
colorectal et on voit bien que
la première idée qui pourrait consister
à dire on écarte le travail de nuit des
conditions de travail des femmes ce qui
serait vraiment une discrimination
premièrement mais secondairement on voit
bien que la science met en évidence
d'autres cancers et que il ne faut pas
se focaliser sur la prévention
uniquement pour les femmes concernant le
travail de nuit et que c'est qu'une
question bien plus large que celle-ci
le deuxième point que je souhaiterais
aborder consiste
à parler d'humain en emploi en
particulier des femmes ce qui fait
partie du quotidien des équipes de santé
au travail je prendrai l'exemple du
cancer parce que c'est un thème qui a
été très très étudié une pathologie très
étudiée ces dernières années
alors je vous ai mis ici quelques
chiffres d'épidémiologie des cancers les
plus fréquents en France qui sont le
cancer du sein le cancer de la prostate
du colon rectum et du poumon vous voyez
qu'en termes de nouveaux cas par an on
est dans des chiffres assez similaires
pour autant ce que je voulais vous
montrer c'est qu'en santé au travail les
cancers auxquels nous sommes confrontés
ne sont pas dans cette répartition qu'on
pourrait voir en termes de nouveaux cas
par an il nous faut prendre en compte
d'autres aspects notamment l'âge médian
au diagnostic par exemple pour le cancer
du sein la moitié des femmes qui ont un
diagnostic de cancer du sein son
diagnostiqué avant l'âge de 63 ans alors
que si vous prenez d'autres cancers
comme le colon rectum c'est plutôt 78
ans la moitié des personnes sont
diagnostiquées après 78 ans le cancer de
la prostate voyez intervient beaucoup
plus tard
le poumon
65 67 ans donc on pourrait se dire bon
ben on a on maintient dans l'emploi
peut-être des personnes qui sont plus
jeunes qui peuvent être affectés par des
maladies plus jeunes donc on ferait
ressortir le cancer du sein et le cancer
du poumon cependant ce qui est important
de regarder c'est aussi le pronostic de
ces maladies et on sait que le pronostic
du cancer du sein c'est largement
amélioré ces 20 dernières années avec
une survie à 5 ans qui est de l'ordre de
87% et on a même encore fait des progrès
pour le cancer du poumon vous voyez que
les chiffres étaient de 17% donc c'est
un cancer de mauvais pronostic qui bien
souvent amène à des difficultés
lorsqu'on souhaite reprendre le travail
même si il y a eu beaucoup beaucoup de
nouveaux travaux sur le cancer du poumon
et que cette survie à 5 ans s'améliore
largement avec l'immunothérapie ces
dernières années donc voilà des
perspectives très intéressantes mais
tout ça pour vous montrer qu'on sentait
au travail on ne peut pas regarder que
le nombre de nouveaux pas de cas par an
mais qu'il y a d'autres éléments
importants et que dans le quotidien
c'est pour ces raisons que en tant que
médecin du travail on est plus souvent
confronté au maintien dans l'emploi de
femmes avec un cancer du sein que par
exemple que d'hommes avec un cancer de
la prostate
je voulais vous montrer aussi ce
graphique qui qui a été publié par
l'INCa il y a quelques années à partir
de l'étude vie qu'en deux et vit qu'en 5
qui a eu lieu par la suite et qui
s'intéresse à l'après cancer il y a tout
un focus sur le travail et celui-ci est
intéressant ce graphique vous montre
une courbe de temps vous avez ici le
temps du diagnostic qui est le temps 0
puis on s'éloigne du diagnostic à six
mois 12 mois 18 mois et 24 mois
il vous montre le taux de personnes qui
sont en emploi au moment du diagnostic
c'est à dire quand on fait un diagnostic
de cancer il y a souvent un arrêt de
travail qui est prescrit et donc on a 17
% des femmes qui sont en arrêt de
travail initialement et 27% des hommes
le retour au travail se fait
progressivement pour atteindre un
plateau entre 18 et 24 mois on va dire
mais on voit que cette courbe elle est
différente chez les hommes et chez les
femmes et que globalement cette étude a
bien montré que les hommes en France en
tout cas reprennent plus vite le travail
que les femmes alors il y a plusieurs
explications à ça bien sûr les cancers
sont différents la vue sur la
diapositive d'avant mais aussi il y a
certainement des questions d'emplois et
de représentation
dans tout ça donc les études se
poursuivent mais en tout cas c'était une
un constat important cette différence de
reprise du travail pour pour les femmes
et les hommes cette bien été montré pour
le cancer et ça l'est pour d'autres
pathologies également
la dernière partie de mon propos très de
la protection de l'enfant à naître alors
j'ai volontairement mais un tel un titre
assez large pour pour vous dire que
souvent quand on parle de protection de
l'enfant et bien ce qu'on est très
sollicité en tant que médecin du travail
pour aménager le poste de travail durant
la grossesse et effectivement pendant la
grossesse on a le foetus qui évolue avec
des périodes de grandes sensibilité lors
de la formation des organes etc mais je
voulais aller replacer ça dans une
perspective beaucoup plus large que l'on
a en tant que en santé au travail pour
dire que la grossesse bien sûr est
importante mais on a tout un stade
auparavant de formation des
spermatozoïdes et qui peuvent être tout
à fait à risque ces trois mois avant la
grossesse donc un focus qu'on devrait
faire beaucoup plus également sur la
protection des hommes pour protéger
l'enfant à l'être et vous parlez aussi
que pour la femme on sait que l'ovule
par exemple est formé non pas dans les
jours précédents la grossesse mais
formez bien avant et il est formé lors
de la
lors de la grossesse de la maman et même
dans les premiers jours de vie de la
petite fille et on a beaucoup de
recherches qui mettent en évidence
probablement des effets sur l'ovule lors
de sa conception donc c'est la toute
petite fille avec des effets
probablement chez l'enfant à naître donc
ça me semblait important de vous parler
de ça parce que il me semble qu'à
l'heure actuelle on parle beaucoup de la
grossesse des aménagements de poste etc
mais qu'il faut à chaque fois se
replacer dans un voilà dans un dans une
continuité beaucoup plus large notamment
d'intoxication chronique je pense au
plomb par exemple qui peut intoxiquer
une jeune femme et qui peut être
et il peut y avoir une intoxication qui
se poursuit pendant la grossesse alors
même qu'elle n'est plus exposée ça me
semble important de considérer cette
protection de l'enfant à naître et non
plus cette protection de la grossesse
voilà
ce que je voulais vous dire ce matin
de quelques exemples du quotidien
j'espère vous avoir montré qu'il y a des
spécificités effectivement de la santé
au travail des femmes mais aussi des
spécificités pour les hommes et que l'on
essaye de prendre en compte tout ça on
sentait au travail que ce soit dans la
prévention dans les consultations
individuelles qu'on peut faire ou dans
le maintien dans l'emploi je vous
remercie de votre attention
merci Madame Roland donc pour cette
présentation que nous avons suivie aussi
sur écran depuis le Sénat donc
maintenant je vais passer la parole à
Madame anne-michel Chartier donc qui est
président du Syndicat général des
médecins et des professionnels des
services de santé au travail c'est à
vous madame
voilà
merci pour votre invitation il se trouve
que je suis aussi médecin du travail que
je propaisse dans un service que
j'exerce dans un service
inter-entreprise et au contact avec les
populations certaines populations que
vous avez cité et
mon invitation m'a amené à me poser des
questions sur ma pratique en tant que
médecin du travail ma pratique comment
je prenais moi-même le genre dans
dans les conditions de travail et bien
ce n'est pas évident effectivement le il
existe
un document unique d'évaluation des
risques dans les entreprises que toutes
les entreprises doivent
remplir et ce document depuis plusieurs
années doit prendre en compte le
caractère j'en Rey des risques au
travail
sauf que c'est très très difficile à
faire à discuter du genre dans les
conditions de travail des entreprises
parce qu'on tombe tout de suite dans un
caractère discriminant et que notre
notre travail est justement de maintenir
au travail des femmes sans forcément
sans justement parler d'une spécificité
de femmes qui pourraient les discriminer
beaucoup en parlaient
les deux personnes auparavant parler du
travail de nuit il est emblématique que
en 1987 il y a un article du code du
travail qui interdisait le travail de
nuit aux femmes dans l'industrie et en
2009 pour l'égalité le travail de nuit a
été réintroduit pour les femmes
l'autre un autre petit exemple
historique du point de vue du travail
des cancers des femmes les femmes qui
étaient les épouses des travailleurs de
l'amiante ont été exposés du fait des
nettoyages les tenues de travail donc
elle n'était pas sur les directement
exposés mais il a fallu reconnaître
comme un collatéral accident de travail
accident maladie professionnelle pour ce
sujet
alors sur ce je continuerai avec la
connaissance des pathologies au travail
des femmes alors il se trouve que dans
mes activités je fais partie du coq et
du cnpst ou sont présentés des
statistiques sur sur les maladies sur la
branche ATMP un moment où on parle de
des statistiques donc il a été montré en
2019 que les femmes le taux d'accident
des femmes diminuait moins que le taux
d'accident des hommes qui diminuent
mieux particulièrement bien et
l'assurance maladie donc la banchâtée
nous a montré ce résultat et on a dit
oui d'accord et comment cela se fait-il
et il se trouve que les statistiques
genré par branche par métier par
exposition existe pas donc on n'a pas eu
la réponse et il paraît que c'est
compliqué parce que c'est quand même
c'est des statistiques très très
importantes sur toutes les branches sur
tous les risques mais pas j'en ré donc
le problème du genre se pose et voilà on
n'a pas eu la réponse et c'était
difficile de
de l'explorer de même
il a été cité le Plan Santé Travail le
Plan Santé Travail 3 comportait un volet
sur les femmes et le croque de Bretagne
a réalisé une enquête sur le travail des
femmes le croque c'est le comité
d'orientation régionale des conditions
de travail à réaliser une enquête sur le
travail des femmes alors travail des
femmes tout à fait descriptifs les
femmes comment elles sont arrêtées
qu'est-ce qui est touché qu'est-ce qui
est bon mais maintenant on espère que en
2023 on va passer à la santé parce que
pour l'instant c'était descriptif
comment les femmes étaient plus étaient
moins donc les femmes bon elles sont
plus exposées aux maladies les hommes
aux accidents mais les hommes ils sont
plus exposés au facteurs de pénibilité
ils ont des métiers plus à risque tout
ça se finalement est assez
compréhensible assez connu mais on
espère ils ont l'intention paraît-il de
continuer leur travail on espère que ça
débouchera sur la santé des femmes
de même il y a une enquête en 2018 de
l'assurance maladie sur les affections
psychiques liées au travail et c'est une
enquête qui portait de 2000 ans à 2016
et il a été noté que les dépressions
chez les femmes étaient plus importantes
de l'ordre de 66 % avec un pic à 44 ans
de même 60% des femmes sont touchées par
le burn out évidemment les secteurs sont
ce que vous avez cités médico-sociaux
transports commerce
les situations déclenchantes étaient
soit un événement brutal soit un
événement révélateur de conditions de
travail donc il y a un facteur
environnement de travail qui est qui est
à mon sens spécifique dans les femmes
comment analyser
alors
j'introduirai le sujet par une
profession particulière que vous avez
cité les mannequins donc c'est
représentants de la féminité c'est leur
physique et leur âge qui est qui a une
importance dans cette profession et je
vous cite deux points
ce qui est bien documenté c'est les
troubles de l'alimentation chez les
mannequins et il y a eu une
un article du code du travail qui a dit
que les mannequins pour pouvoir profer
pour pouvoir exercer devait passer une
visite médicale tous les ans justement
et avoir un certificat médical qui
interdisait au mannequin anorexiques de
de professer
donc les mannequins anorexiques oui mais
pourquoi la norrexie
c'est bien de dire bah vous travaillerez
pas ça serait quand même plus
sympathique de dire pourquoi vous êtes
adoré de
de même les mannequins qui sont des
professions que l'on perçoit comme
privilégié
et c'est une profession qui violente
parce que cette violence de l'apparition
physique fait que les mannequins
travaillent entre 16 ans et 35 ans et
ensuite sont renvoyés à leur âge et sont
précarisés fragilisés parce qu'elles ne
trouvent plus de travail les mannequins
sont des intérimaires elles sont prêtés
par des sociétés qui pour faire des
photographies pour faire des défis
d'où encore on travaille où on travaille
pas c'est le c'est la société
utilisatrice qui choisit donc il y a des
pressions et des agressions sexistes des
des violences sexistes qui sont
appréhender dans un contexte mais un
contexte qui est pas j'ai à faire un
pervers narcissique ou
un petit copain mais
pourquoi le système a toujours accepté
ces violences pourquoi le système ne les
dénonce pas pourquoi le système ne les
prend pas en compte donc il s'est
violent de ces violences faites aux
femmes vous savez vous puisque vous avez
travaillé sur les RPS et les troubles
musculoosquelettiques vous savez très
bien vous avez appris que les violents
les risques psychosociaux entraîner ces
troubles musculus squelettiques et quand
j'entends que les femmes sont plus on
décrivent plus de troubles muscleuses
qui étaient plutôt il convient de
s'interroger sur ses violences subies
dans les dans ces professions donc j'ai
cité cette enquête cette cette
profession des mannequins parce que les
mannequins sont suivis dans un centre
exclusifs qui surveille tous les
mannequins de France et ils ont décidé
justement de cibler sur une enquête sur
cette profession en trouvant que elle
était comme elle était c'était une
profession justement qui était
maltraitée avec des violences donc une
enquête et est en cours dans ce centre
à partir de cet exemple emblématique je
pourrais élargir au métier du car au
métier de la personne au métier des
ménages ou on retrouve ces mêmes
violences
ce sont des femmes qui sont précaires
avec des métiers peu rémunérés à temps
partiel avec des violences qui peuvent
survenir du client puisque c'est cité
dans les violences tout ce qui est en
rapport avec la clientèle peut provoquer
des violences des exigences de
l'employeur parce qu'il y a des pertes
de contrats quand on travaille dans les
métiers de l'aide à la personne à
domicile la personne peut décéder ou
être hospitalisée il y a plus de mais il
y a plus de travail donc c'est au bon
vouloir de l'employeur qui va donner ou
non qui va redonner un contrat ou pas à
la personne qui travaille bien qui a
accepté de faire des heures
supplémentaires qui a accepté de se
déplacer de travailler le dimanche
et elle sera assurée d'avoir plus de
travail que celle qui pour d'autres
raisons va peut-être le refuser
l'environnement peut-être violent aussi
parce que ces femmes habitent des zones
qui sont assez éloignées de leur lieu de
travail et qui sont peu sécurisés et
comme les horaires sont décalés dans
toutes ces professions du cœur des
hôtesses de caisse
ça les cela les amène à retourner chez
elle alors que l'environnement est pas
sûr elles peuvent aussi être agressés
donc toute cette violence
systématique systémique des femmes est
analyser parce qu'elle est le lit de
troubles musculo-squelettiques et je
dirais même plus elle est le lit de
l'usure c'est de ce sentiment d'usure
c'est à dire qu'après avoir été arrêté
après avoir un arrêt de travail et ça a
été noté pourquoi on a du mal à revenir
au travail mais parce qu'il y a ce
sentiment d'usure de difficulté au
quotidien de violence dans traf
ça je continuerai en faisant un petit
focus parce que je suis donc présidente
mais pour une confédération qui est la
CFE-CGC qui s'intéresse aux femmes et
qui s'intéressent au cadre et le vous
avez cité la pandémie et pendant la
pandémie la CFE-CGC avait fait une
enquête auprès des cadres sur les
conditions de management pendant la
pandémie et pendant le
et avec un petit focus sur la parité sur
le genre et les femmes c'était plaintes
que les enfants étaient à leur charge
c'est elle qui devait s'occuper des
enfants et que le télétravail à domicile
avait pas été du tout été pensé avec des
femmes et des enfants et que ça ça avait
été une quelque chose qui était
excessivement dur
en tant que cFECGC nous avons choisi de
continuer à travailler sur le management
le management qui a été donc un
révélateur pendant la pandémie et nous
avons décidé de continuer à travailler
parce que le management intermédiaire
est un management qui souffre aussi au
point que les métiers du management ne
sont plus choisis ne sont pas forcément
remplies parce que il y a des
contraintes qui sont importantes pour
ces métiers qui sont compris entre le
top management et le manage et les
salariés et que ces contraintes
nous allons les étudier et nous allons
les étudier avec une vision que l'on va
que l'on va genrer pour voir comment on
va trouver pourquoi ces femmes sont plus
exposées au risque de Burn Out quel est
ce côté systémique de violence qui fait
que les femmes sont plus exposées
au burn-out voilà donc et l'objectif
c'est d'avoir un guide sur les bonnes
pratiques de management et de tout bon
donc en résumé il existe dans le travail
des femmes une maltraitance
organisationnelle qu'il convient de de
travailler plus en profondeur pour ne
pas s'arrêter à des cas individuels ne
pas s'arrêter à ben c'est la faute du
manager puisque nous travaillons sur ce
sujet donc pour nous et dans ma pratique
travailler sur les risques sur les
facteurs de risque sur les facteurs de
risque psychosociaux sociales et
absolument déterminant pour pouvoir
avancer sur ces sujets qui donnent une
qui quelque part font que
toute la santé des femmes est impactée
par cette
usure mentale cette violence et et ses
sentiments
merci de m'avoir écouté
merci beaucoup madame Chartier donc je
vais essayer de la parole à Magalie
Chevassu qui est psychologue du travail
et membre du réseau présence merci pour
cette présentation complète madame
madame la Présidente Mesdames les
rapporteurs je vous remercie d'avoir
souhaité entendre la voix de ma
profession et j'espère la portée de la
manière la plus juste possible je
remercie également chaleureusement le
docteur leteux de présentationale qui
m'a transmis l'invitation et l'ensemble
de mes collègues qui a bien sûr
contribué à compiler ses arguments pour
vous alors comment prendre en compte la
santé physique et mentale des femmes au
travail alors tout d'abord très
rapidement quelques petits propos les
chiffres que je vais vous présenter bien
évidemment c'est un échantillon infime
de la population générale donc il serait
pas être représentatif de cette
population le psychologue en santé au
travail n'a pas accès à une immense
partie de la population parce qu'elle va
bien parce qu'elle n'en voit pas
l'intérêt parce qu'elle est orientée
ailleurs vers d'autres professionnels ou
parce qu'elle est en désinsertion
professionnelle donc on a forcément pas
accès dans nos locaux aux personnes qui
ne travaillent pas
les propos que je vais soumettre à votre
écoute donc sont à entendre comme des
hypothèses de travail ou en tout cas des
constats empiriques issus d'une pratique
et non des conclusions vérifiées et ces
constats ne présupposent d'ailleurs pas
de la part dîner ou d'Aki dans les
comportements masculins et féminins
alors sur la ismt13 qui est le mon
service alors c'est une un service
inter-entreprise
qui comprend 13110 entreprises
adhérentes pour un total de 165 000
salariés sur ces salariés
47,5% sont des femmes donc on a une
proportion finalement à peu près égale
homme-femme en revanche l'écart se
creuses sur la population des cadres
puisque 40% des femmes
occupent ces fonctions là ce qui dénote
quand même un écart important
ce qui va concerner les inaptitudes sur
les cinq dernières années les chiffres
sont assez stables même très stables on
est plutôt sur 65% d'inaptitude
prononcées sur des femmes alors certes
chez nous il y a un billet de
recrutement puisque on donnait de
nombreux adhérents sont dans le secteur
de la grande distribution de l'aide à
domicile d'une nettoyage ou du soin ou
du médico-social donc on est sur des
secteurs qui sont de toute façon très
occupées par des femmes ça peut
contribuer à expliquer une partie des
inaptitudes et pas juste de dire que les
femmes le seul argument n'est pas que il
y a les femmes souffrent plus en tout
cas on a un échantillon on a aussi
parfois des femmes qui sont très
représentées dans les secteurs qui sont
difficiles et usant
sur ces inaptitudes alors globale 40%
sont prononcés pour trouble mentaux et
du comportement c'est comme ça que la
nomenclature le dit réellement qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire des
troubles anxieux souvent pour les femmes
des difficultés à gérer la pression
managériale parce que le travail est
dénigré parce qu'on leur fait des
reproches sur l'organisation personnelle
parce que il y a une remise en question
de leur capacité au travail
ces chiffres corroborent un petit peu
nos orientations vers la cellule de
prévention de la désinsertion
professionnelle puisqu'elle vont
concerner
beaucoup de femmes en tout cas à partir
de 35 ans on est sur 60% de femmes
orientées vers ces services de maintien
en emploi
alors sur les consultations
psychologiques maintenant on a une
proportion en femme de salariés qui sont
orientés vers les psychologues qui est
très équivalente à celle qui se
saisissent de la démarche et ça
correspond aussi à ces fameux 65% donc
finalement on a deux tiers de femmes
qu'on oriente faire les psychologues et
deux tiers de femmes en consultation moi
je note quand même un fait intéressant
c'est à dire que lorsque les personnes
ne viennent pas à mon bureau mais que
c'est moi qui vais dans l'entreprise
cette fois-ci c'est des hommes qui
viennent me voir
j'y reviendrai un petit peu plus tard
en consultation en tout cas sur la
population des cadres je note que une
femme sur quatre
occupe un poste de cadre et un homme sur
trois
occupe un poste de cas donc on a un peu
moins d'encadrant dans les consultations
donc on cadran te
et là aussi je vais y revenir un petit
peu plus tard ce que je remarque aussi
sur nos chiffres
issus de notre service c'est que les
femmes viennent beaucoup plus tôt alors
comment interpréter ces chiffres et
c'est comme ça que je vais chapitrer mon
intervention d'une part des modalités
particulières d'exposition au risque
psychosociaux d'autre part des modalités
particulières d'expression symptomatique
il existe également dans le travail des
spécificités liées aux représentations
sociales de la femme et des spécificités
liées au poste à responsabilité
alors je me permets un petit rappel sur
les risques psychosociaux l'idée étant
de bien souligner que dans la prévention
des risques psychosociaux l'enjeu n'est
pas seulement de diminuer les facteurs
de risque mais aussi d'augmenter les
facteurs de ressources puisque c'est un
finalement un savant équilibre entre
l'existence de facteurs de risque qu'on
reconnaît mais aussi l'existence de
facteurs de dans lesquels on va pouvoir
puiser de l'énergie de la satisfaction
qui vont nous permettre de ne pas
souffrir d'une situation de travail en
revanche si les facteurs de risque sont
trop représentés là bien évidemment on
voit apparaître l'ensemble de ce qu'on
appelle les troubles psychosociaux que
sont le stress le burn out les conflits
les troubles addictifs à visées
d'adaptatif les TMS etc
alors les troubles les risques
psychosociaux pardon sont définis par
Michel collak comme des conditions
d'emplois des facteurs relationnels et
organisationnels susceptibles
d'interagir avec le fonctionnement
mental dans le détail on a quelques
grandes familles qui reviennent et qu'on
va analyser notamment l'intensité et le
temps de travail soit les exigences de
la tâche et de la performance alors dans
cette famille de facteurs de risque ce
qu'on va remarquer chez les femmes ce
sont les tentes partiels plus fréquents
mais qui ne sont pas forcément corrélés
à une baisse de la charge de travail il
est très habituel de voir une femme qui
travaille sur un poste à 80% par exemple
mais qui a une charge de travail à temps
plein parce que l'employeur n'a pas
forcément les moyens de prendre 20% pour
combler ce temps de travail tout
simplement c'est souvent le cas
d'ailleurs au retour des congés
maternité où on prend un congé parental
avec une diminution du temps de travail
mais on n'a pas une diminution du
travail qui est associée
les rythmes de travail sont par ailleurs
très exigeants dans les secteurs dit
féminins les hôtesses de caisse la ligne
de caisse fonctionne doit fonctionner
quoi qu'il arrive les toilettes par
exemple dans les dans les milieux
médicaux
tout ça est bien évidemment couplé avec
une charge mentale il y a l'organisation
familiale
sur la deuxième famille de facteurs de
risque qui est l'autonomie et la marge
de manœuvre alors on a de toute façon
une proportion moindre d'encadrante ce
qui veut dire aussi que sur une on a
plus de femmes en position subalterne
qui n'a pas forcément de possibilité
d'être concerté sur son travail de
participer aux décisions qui vont
impacter son travail et donc le
sentiment d'être un petit peu plus à
l'étroit dans un cadre de travail auquel
il va falloir s'adapter
les secteurs d'activité par ailleurs
féminin comprennent en général des
procédures qui sont lourdes des
protocoles des des manières de faire les
choses qui sont très encadrées des
produits à utiliser pour le secteur de
l'entretien avec finalement peu de
latitude pour conseiller peut-être autre
chose une autre manière de faire ce sont
également des secteurs où on remarque
peu de possibilités de parcours
d'évolution ou de reconversion
sur la famille des conflits de valeurs
des conflits éthiques alors c'est une
famille qui est très enfin qui est très
exposée en fonction du niveau de
responsabilité ou du secteur d'activité
notamment les secteurs du Caire qui vont
faire qui vont amener les salariés à
faire face à la souffrance ou en tout
cas aux difficultés des personnes
on est dans une potentialisation de ce
risque là alors je remarque pas
forcément une différence en terme
d'exposition dans cette famille de
facteurs de risque moi ce que je
remarque en cabinet c'est une différence
au niveau des conséquences sur la santé
je m'explique les conflits de valeur
ce sont des conflits finalement à
l'intérieur de moi il y a une partie de
moi qui défend mon système de valeurs
entre ce qui est juste ce qui est
mauvais entre ce qui est bien ce qui est
mal et une partie de moi qui fait un
comportement que je suis souvent obligé
de faire parce que mon travail me le
demande
ces deux parties de moi dans un conflit
de valeurs ne sont pas d'accord on me
demande de faire quelque chose qui va à
l'encontre de ceux en quoi je crois
il se passe à ce moment-là un mal-être
très particulier lié à ce qu'on appelle
la dissonance cognitive dont il va
falloir sortir problème c'est que c'est
assez binaire la résolution de la
dissonance de la dissonance cognitive
c'est soit je maintiens mon système de
valeurs mais là il faut que je trouve un
moyen de sortir de ce milieu qui le
maltraite soit jamais nage mon système
de valeurs de manière à justifier le
comportement que j'ai et bien les femmes
ça c'est mon constat ça ne regarde que
moi attaquer moi si c'est faux mais en
tout cas moi ce que je remarque c'est
que les femmes tiennent plus longtemps
dans cet état de conflit psychique
interne elles arrivent plus longtemps à
faire des compromis sans forcément en
fait elles tiennent dans la négociation
avec l'employeur en essayant de défendre
un système de valeurs alors que
finalement un homme va peut-être plus
rapidement que claquer la porte ou plus
rapidement se dire bon bah oui
finalement je pensais ça mais finalement
c'est comme ça qu'il faut faire
les conflits de valeur sont alors soit
sont intensifiés ou intensifie le
problème de charge de travail énormément
dans les milieux médico-sociaux avec la
question aussi des TMS notamment par
exemple sur des questions de la toilette
on a des quotas de personnels on a des
quotas de toilettes par personne en fait
l'idée c'est pas tellement la charge de
travail qui va poser problème c'est le
la capacité à bien faire son travail en
particulier quand ça va impliquer
une conséquence sur quelqu'un une
personne âgée qui ce matin-là et
peut-être plus difficile à lever qui est
peut-être de mauvaise humeur plus
difficile à toiletter va forcément
impacter le rythme des toilettes et
on remarque en tout cas chez les
personnes qui soignent que c'est pas
tellement d'avoir à faire 10 à 12
toilettes en deux heures c'est de
pouvoir les faire bien
quatrième famille de facteurs de risque
psychosociaux les exigences
émotionnelles alors les exigences
émotionnelles c'est tout ce qui va me
demander en fait de travailler sur mes
émotions de faire en sorte qu'elle
impacte pas mon travail de pouvoir
rester neutre voire même jovial parce
qu'il y a des exigences même dans les
professions commerciales il faut pouvoir
être aimable et avenant
alors ce qu'on remarque c'est que ces
exigences là se cumulent avec les
exigences émotionnelles dans la famille
avec les soins qu'on va apporter à la
famille les femmes d'ailleurs sont plus
souvent statut des dents on parle pas
juste aux soins des enfants
la fièvre accompagnée chez le médecin on
parle aussi aux soins du parents âgé
soit un parfois aussi des de la fratrie
handicapée
avec j'y reviendrai tout à l'heure des
différences d'expressions émotionnelles
chez la femme et chez l'homme
là aussi je l'articule avec les risques
TMS notamment dans les secteurs du soin
et la petite enfance parce que même si
ce sont des secteurs ou il y a des
appareils de portage qui sont tout à
fait opérationnels sauf que c'est
douloureux pour certaines femmes pour
les éducatrices pour les
aides-soignantes finalement de ne pas
pouvoir offrir la chaleur des bras et
même dans les crèches finalement ou
parfois certaines personnes qui sont
sous restriction médicale parce qu'il y
a des douleurs dorsales et d'autres
douleurs qui qui devraient les empêcher
de porter et ben c'est difficile de pas
être dans la dans le holding pour
reprendre un terme sur lequel je
reviendrai aussi un petit peu tout à
l'heure
cinquième famille de facteurs de risque
les rapports sociaux et la
reconnaissance au travail alors les
métiers dit féminins sont parfois quand
même peu valorisés il faut le dire les
métiers d'entretien la grande
distribution c'est pas c'est pas
folichon ce sont des métiers qui sont
reconnus comme usant et qui sont aussi
plus exposés au risque d'agression parce
que justement pas forcément très
valorisé et puis les hôtesses d'accueil
les hôtesses de caisse
sont pas forcément toujours très bien
traités
il y a un manque de reconnaissance de
l'investissement dans le travail
beaucoup d'entreprises aujourd'hui parce
que c'est très factuel et c'est
peut-être plus facile reconnaissent
uniquement le résultat du travail sauf
qu'en fait très souvent ce qui importe
c'est la reconnaissance existentielle de
qui je suis bonjour madame comment
allez-vous mais c'est aussi la
reconnaissance du processus de travail
qu'est-ce que j'ai eu qu'est-ce que je
mets comme effort pour réussir à faire
ce travail à produire ce résultat est-ce
que j'y ai mis plus de temps est-ce que
je suis allée approfondir mes
connaissances est-ce que j'ai mis plus
d'implication plus de soucis émotionnels
et ça finalement c'est une partie qui
reste très invisible et qui peut faire
souffrir
j'en viens également aux problématiques
d'insertion alors des minorités dans les
milieux d'hommes finalement les femmes
qui exercent dans les milieux d'hommes
alors soit elles exercent le même métier
mais avec finalement pas mal de
remarques sexistes ou autres soit en
fait elles y sont mais sur des postes
administratifs donc très quelque chose
de très clivé
là on peut voir apparaître des questions
alors j'ai mis les guillemets
harcèlement parce que c'est une notion
juridique et que au stade où les femmes
nous arrivent on peut pas forcément le
qualifier de harcèlement en tout cas pas
juridiquement par contre ce qu'on
remarque c'est qu'elles sont très
sensibles au manque de bienveillance
c'est à dire que le dans l'environnement
de travail on ne prête pas forcément
attention à l'impact de la manière dont
on va dire les choses de des propos
qu'on va choisir
et du coup elles vont être elles pour le
coup très concernés par voilà pourquoi
est-ce qu'on m'a dit ça comme ça de
cette manière là en choisissant ce mot
là
et j'en fais aussi à quelque chose qui
est peut-être plus alors
je sais pas si c'est plus féminin que
Max que masculin en tout cas les femmes
se comparent beaucoup entre elles sur le
milieu de travail et on voit des
conflits générationnels assez importants
entre les représentations des jeunes
femmes et le représentations des femmes
plus mûres dans le travail
et j'en viens enfin pour clore sur les
risques les facteurs de risque
psychosociaux sur l'insécurité de la
situation de travail des choses qui vous
ont déjà été rapportées au sein de cette
commission les carrières hachées les
interruptions pour grossesse et congés
parentaux qui peuvent porter préjudice à
la progression à la progression de
carrière
alors pour en venir au deuxième chapitre
de ma présentation sur les modalités
d'expression des symptômes les femmes en
consultation clinique ont une
particularité elles vont exprimer
beaucoup plus souvent de la culpabilité
elle pleure plus souvent aussi
elles mettent plus en avant en termes de
positif leur capacité d'adaptation et
leur esprit collectif le sentiment de
faire un travail utile et pour elle un
facteur d'épanouissement par contre elle
se sent étiquetée plus fragile c'est ce
que moi je mets en lien avec le fait que
quand je suis en entreprise c'est
peut-être plus facilement les hommes qui
viennent tout simplement parce que les
femmes se sont déjà stigmatisées et que
donc si en plus on va on va rentrer dans
la salle avec le psychologue on va venir
confirmer le fait qu'effectivement je
suis plus fragile
je reviens aussi sur l'analyse des
pleurs
[Musique]
qui pour moi est absolument pas le signe
d'une fragilité plus importante c'est au
contraire le signe d'une meilleure
régulation de des émotions et d'une
meilleure capacité à réguler ses
émotions elles sont moins bloquées à
l'intérieur et elles agissent moins sur
le long terme
en tout cas les femmes montrent des
compétences on va dire plus précoce et
plus précise en termes de repérage des
symptômes de stress elles savent mieux
si elles souffrent de symptômes
physiologiques du stress elles savent
mieux repérer les situations de ce qui
vont les stresser et les techniques qui
va falloir mettre en oeuvre pour éviter
ces situations ou pour y faire face en
général du coup elles sont plus à
l'écoute de leur corps et de leurs
émotions par contre ça contraste
énormément avec leur tendance à
prioriser les besoins de l'autre donc
elles vont pas venir en consultation pas
parce qu'elles ne sentent pas le besoin
mais parce qu'elle sentiront qu'il y a
d'autres priorités et d'autres personnes
à qui s'occuper les hommes en
consultation ont exprimé beaucoup plus
facilement des douleurs ou de la colère
ou de la fatigue ils vont venir plus
tard plus abîmés en fait moi je pense
que pour beaucoup d'entre eux c'est tout
simplement qu'il y a des dépressions
masquées qui n'ont pas été repérées et
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'on nous les
oriente moins pas forcément parce qu'il
souffre moins mais parce qu'il le masque
plus
eux en tout cas en honte de craquer
si vraiment on a un homme qui pleure en
consultation c'est vraiment quelque
chose je veux dire avec beaucoup de
tendresse parce qu'à chaque fois c'est
quelque chose de précieux qui nous est
déposé mais c'est attention je vais
pleurer c'est on nous prévient c'est
ils mettent plus en avant leur autonomie
et leur capacité à prendre des
initiatives et le fait pour de pouvoir
évoluer et pour eux un facteur
d'épanouissement
la banalisation des difficultés par les
femmes et plus grande si la famille est
monoparentale parce qu'elle se donne une
interdiction de faillir
ou si elles occupent une position de
cadre parce que là encore il faut
pouvoir rationaliser le stress qui fait
partie du métier ou en tout cas prouver
qu'on mérite le poste donc on y met
débouchés doubles pour montrer qu'on est
à la hauteur de la tâche
je conclus ce propos en parlant des
transformations psychiques profondes qui
sont inhérentes à n'importe quel
parcours de maternité que ce soit les
accouchements les adoptions les fausses
couches les parcours PMA qui sont très
laborieux les échecs
l'allaitement le sommeil du nourrisson
les pathologies du nourrisson les
pathologies liées à l'accouchement aussi
tout ça peut avoir un impact alors
positif ou négatif sur l'estime de soi
sur la confiance en soi sur le sentiment
de légitimité et d'efficacité
personnelle et tout ça va bien
évidemment agir comme caisse de
résonance sur les difficultés qu'on peut
rencontrer au travail soit en venant les
atténuer parce que si je me sens mieux
dans mes baskets parce que j'ai réussi
certains objectifs personnels je vais
pouvoir mieux tolérer ce qui se passe
dans mon milieu de travail et puis
inversement si j'arrive pas à accomplir
certaines choses je peux être très
sensible à des difficultés qui se
présentent à moi dans le travail mais je
veux dire c'est propre aussi au
messieurs
alors quelques remarques sur la
particularité du stress d'origine
psychologique c'est une double
appréciation en fait j'apprécie à la
fois de manière subjective la contrainte
qui met imposée et j'apprécie aussi de
manière subjective les ressources que
j'ai pour y faire face donc je peux me
tromper doublement je peux me tromper
sur la gravité de cette contrainte qui
m'est imposée et je peux me tromper sur
l'efficacité des ressources que j'ai à
ma disposition ce qui parfois amène à
des différences en termes de stress
ressenti parce que ces messieurs souvent
vont avoir tendance à quand il
ressentent du stress surévaluer la
contrainte qui leur est imposée alors
que à stress équivalent en fait la dame
va pas forcément surévaluer la
contrainte mais elle va sous-évaluer ses
ressources
donc encore une fois en lien avec la
conscience la confiance en soi l'estime
de soi des femmes
la santé psychique dépend de la capacité
à intégrer les expériences positives et
négatives et faire face aux défis avec
le sentiment d'être en capacité
d'affronter les conséquences
la nature humaine est essentiellement
multidimensionnelle et à l'implique de
traverser des phases de transformation
parfois radicale en fonction des étapes
de la vie et quid du code du travail et
de l'article l4121-2 alinéa 4 quand
est-ce qu'on adapte le travail alors à
l'homme non pas avec un petit âge
excusez-moi mais avec un grand H hein il
s'agit aussi d'adapter le travail à la
femme mais je j'ai un petit peu de mal à
le voir il y a quelques exemples quand
même mais mais trop peu à mon sens
enfin l'acceptation du vieillissement
est rendue beaucoup plus difficile
socialement pour les femmes que pour les
hommes c'est bien qu'on s'est bien
entendu une femme plus avancée dans
l'âge plus de chances d'être considérée
comme plus usé moins efficace alors
qu'un homme plus avancé un homme plus
avancé dans l'âge et plus expérimenté
plus outillés plus légitime etc alors
quelques représentations sociales
stéréotypées au travail pendant 3e
chapitre alors les femmes et les hommes
vivent une éducation émotionnelle en
tout cas pour ma génération encore
peut-être c'est peut-être moins vrai
pour les générations d'après très genré
les petites filles
sont pas forcément
entre guillemets autorisé à exprimer
beaucoup de colère on sent bien que la
tendue social est pas là en revanche en
légitime beaucoup leur tristesse on les
accompagne beaucoup et c'est peut-être
l'inverse total pour les hommes ou là
bon finalement il y a pas trop de
problèmes à ce que les petits garçons
soient en mais par contre il s'agirait
quand même pas de pleurer parce que
sinon on aura du mal à devenir un homme
bon heureusement ça change un petit peu
l'éducation pour les filles de manière
générale les plus protectrice alors
c'est très bien je n'ai rien contre ça
le problème c'est que en sous-jacent
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'on est que les femmes sont des
victimes potentielles et qu'elles sont
donc des proies dans un milieu de
prédateur donc du coup peut-être que on
peut se poser la question des
hésitations de la femme plus importante
à prendre des risques que par rapport
aux hommes
autre question qui moi me titille ce
qu'on appelle la préoccupation
maternelle primaire qui est un état
presque fusionnel finalement de la maman
avec son petit bébé qui est censé
prendre naissance vers la fin de la
grossesse et prendre fin quelques mois
après l'accouchement
moi j'ai un problème avec ça ça a été
décrit par un homme comme une pathologie
mentale d'allure schizoïdes et
transitoire
et moi je me demande en fait et si
c'était faux tout simplement déjà est-ce
que est-ce que c'est est-ce que ce
serait pas faux que ces transitoire
parce que en fait finalement même quand
ils ont 25 ans les enfants je pense pas
que les femmes soient coupées de leurs
besoins
essentiels et si c'était pas une
pathologie mentale en fait et si c'était
ça la normalité d'être capable d'être à
l'écoute des émotions de l'autre et
d'être à l'écoute des besoins de l'autre
oui
la PMP la préoccupation maternelle
primaire
voilà
et si c'était et si c'était ça qui était
normal en fait et si c'était ça qui
était inhibé chez les hommes cette
capacité finalement à être en connexion
à ressentir les besoins de l'autre et à
pouvoir y répondre si c'est juste
il y a également des attendus sociaux
autour de la vulnérabilité de la douceur
alors qu'ils font que la charge mentale
émotionnelle qui sont invisibles ne vont
pas entraîner de reconnaissance
particulière et donc dans les milieux du
Caire ça pose problème
il y a un paradoxe qui est énorme entre
oui effectivement une femme doit être 12
vulnérables s'occuper des enfants etc
mais en même temps on stigmatise les
femmes qui vont prioriser l'éducation
des enfants sur leur insertion
professionnelle et puis en fait tout
simplement on va dévaloriser la femme
qui est en position d'autorité et qui va
l'affirmer parce que du coup très
facilement c'est pas c'est plus
l'autorité légitime du manager c'est la
méchante puisqu'elle est pas censée être
ferme à l'essentiel être douce et
bienveillante
donc voilà quelques paradoxes auxquels
les femmes font face et puis bien
évidemment aussi les attentes autour de
la maternité qui stigmatise les femmes
qui font le choix de pas avoir d'enfant
ou qui peuvent pas en avoir
les hommes à côté vont s'autoriser très
difficilement une forme de fragilité en
tout cas qu'ils estiment comme une
fragilité et puis il va y avoir des
stéréotypes aussi sur l'ambition et la
quête de pouvoir dans le sens où les
autoritarismes masculins vont être plus
facilement légitimés par les femmes un
patron qui me parle mal finalement c'est
pas forcément un méchant c'est juste un
patron
sauf si et quand même
il est dans une position de pouvoir qui
est perçue comme illégitime parce que il
a peut-être pas montré ces capacités à
manager correctement ou parce qu'il
exerce son pouvoir par la séduction ou
la manipulation alors là les femmes sont
très très efficaces à repérer ce genre
d'illumine dit légitimité de pouvoir
j'en viens au poste à responsabilité
alors le code du travail indique
implique en tout cas des obligations de
moyens et de résultats de l'employeur
vis-à-vis de la santé de la sécurité des
travailleurs
ce qui fait que le rôle prescrit du
manager
en termes de disponibilité d'écoute de
rôle protecteur contenant c'est une
posture de soutien ça c'est sur le
papier dans les faits dans le travail
réel la posture du manager c'est une
posture tournée vers la performance vers
la pression vers le contrôle la
vérification la surveillance la
transmission de consignes avec le fait
d'être garant de leur application et ça
pour le middle management c'est souvent
un vrai problème pourquoi parce que la
responsabilité sans les moyens d'agir
parce qu'on est d'accord que middle
management il a pas forcément beaucoup
de latitudes il applique ce qu'on lui
demande d'en haut et il compose avec les
contraintes qui viennent d'en bas
qu'est-ce qui se passe je suis
responsable mais j'ai pas les moyens
d'agir je me culpabilise
alors la responsabilité la femme elle
sait faire la disponibilité la femme
elle sait être ça fait partie du bagage
féminin en revanche sur ces postes là la
femme anticipe très très bien la balance
gratification sacrifice quand même la
balance bénéfice risque pour employer un
terme peut-être plus à la mode
la femme va être sur ses postes-là en
conflit sur les représentations entre la
compatibilité de la vie de famille et le
travail et moi je me demande pourquoi
parce que finalement oui certains le
cadre on travaille souvent au forfait
jour etc mais finalement les milieux du
Caire les milieux de la grande
distribution il y a aussi très très peu
de disponibilités on est sur des
travailleurs de week-end de soirée donc
finalement
la compatibilité vie de famille et poste
de management elle est pas forcément
moindre que dans d'autres secteurs
d'activité ou dans d'autres niveaux de
la hiérarchie enfin les femmes ont un
sentiment d'illégitimité plus prononcé
que celui des hommes sur quand on leur
demande leur opinion sur ces sur ses
postes là
alors quelques pistes de réflexion
puisqu'on parle du comment mieux prendre
en compte la santé des femmes au travail
je pense que il est aussi important de
changer le regard social pour pouvoir
changer le travail
question question ouverte l'encarant
doit-il être responsable du travail
fourni par ses collaborateurs comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui où est-ce qu'il
doit être responsable des collaborateurs
eux-mêmes responsables de leur travail
dans le milieu du Caire dans le milieu
dans les milieux sociaux
[Musique]
peu de salariés travaillent pour leur
direction
en fait les salariés travaillent pour
leur public pour leur passion pour leur
résident
et c'est pas ça qui se passe finalement
sur le terrain alors si on envisage que
le responsable doit être responsable du
collaborateur de son bien-être de sa
capacité à travailler on présuppose du
coup en recrutement qui n'est plus
uniquement sur une compétence juste
technique mais aussi sur d'autres formes
de compétences ça suppose aussi qu'il
faut amplifier les efforts de formation
des managers aux indicateurs de mal-être
à la communication excusez-moi il y a un
mot qui est parti à l'écoute et qui ne
soit pas axée sur la rentabilité avec à
la clé un vrai bénéfice secondaire sur
la prévention des risques psychosociaux
puisqu'on va gagner en latitude
décisionnelle et puis on va améliorer
les relations collaborateurs encadrant
dont on sait qu'elles sont pas les
meilleures
enfin plus on est au plus on est seul
évidemment ça c'est la forme de la
pyramide en bas on est des équipiers on
est un groupe on a un collectif et puis
plus on monte plus on est isolé alors
est-ce qu'on peut promouvoir la
transversalité des projets partagés ne
serait-ce que pour alléger pardon on la
charge cognitive décomposer les
problèmes complexes mais aussi
finalement améliorer il s'agit pas
tellement de de rendre de mettre plus de
femmes dans des postes d'encarant mais
c'est aussi sur ces postes là qu'elles
soient peut-être plus satisfaite et
mieux en phase avec leurs besoins et
pourquoi pas instaurer systématiquement
des partages de bonnes pratiques entre
encadrant pour renforcer un sentiment
d'appartenance de légitimité puisqu'on
sait qu'elle se sentit légitime
de diminuer la charge cognitive et de
renforcer le sentiment d'efficacité et
enfin je suis tombée sur une conclusion
qui m'a beaucoup étonné mais que
finalement oui je suis obligé de la
partager il y a
plus de chance pour les femmes de
bénéficier de promotion interne ça a été
noté dans un rapport de Ben David et
banlie de 2022 alors pourquoi en fait et
c'est vrai qu'en consultation moi ce que
les femmes me rapportent c'est que si
elles veulent évoluer on va leur
demander de changer alors de changer
d'antenne de d'avoir une mutation parce
qu'elle cône elle connaissent trop et
bon pourquoi finalement qu'est-ce que ça
implique de trop connaître ses collègues
est-ce que est-ce qu'on les manage moins
bien est-ce qu'on se fait moins bien
obéir je ne sais pas est-ce que c'est
pas tout simplement la peur du lien
peut-être la peur qu'une femme aurait
peut-être plus de chance à favoriser les
unes ou les autres sur des critères
émotionnels plutôt que sur des critères
de de
travail en fait pourquoi est-ce qu'on
pense qu'une femme est moins apte qu'un
homme
à bénéficier d'une promotion interne
c'est une vraie question le regard
sociétal et la confiance alors sur le
congé maternité
en France finalement il y a beaucoup de
femmes qui ont peur de se congé
maternité elles ont peur de pas
retrouver le même travail une fois
qu'elles seront parties et finalement il
est assez court
moi je contraste ça avec l'Allemagne
finalement il est très mal vu de revenir
au travail moins d'un an après
l'accouchement
pourquoi parce qu'en fait on investit la
femme d'une d'un rôle très important de
d'éducation de formation d'un futur
membre de la Société et que finalement
si on privilégie son travail et bien on
est un petit peu égoïste un petit peu en
marge des besoins sociétaux c'est pas du
tout le cas en France où finalement ben
non il faut vite vite revenir au travail
parce que sinon ça veut dire qu'on
s'intéresse pas à la société bon
pourquoi ne pas réfléchir au meilleur
encadrement des remplacements il y a
beaucoup de femmes qui reviennent de
congé maternité pour se voir attribuer
un poste différent
quel vivre comme une vraie dégradation
comme une vraie dévalorisation parfois
même c'est leur remplaçante pendant le
congé maternité qui va occuper leur
poste une fois qu'elle revienne donc il
y a vraiment une réflexion à mener je
pense là-dessus le renforcement du
soutien au maire allaitantes pourquoi
pas systématiser alors là je lance des
pistes comme ça systématiser les
conseillères en allaitement et pourquoi
pas les congés allaitement pourquoi pas
re rémunérer les pauses allaitement
alors j'ai trouvé du coup dans le cadre
de ses recherches une vieille
proposition de loi qui a été adoptée par
la Chambre députés en 1913 où il est
stipulé qu'il est interdit de décompter
en aucune façon du montant du salaire
journalier leur destinée à allaitement à
l'allaitement qu'est-ce qui a fait que
ça a disparu c'est sûrement le progrès
la modern beaucoup de choses en tout cas
certes si on en si on voit les choses
sous l'angle économique l'allaitement
c'est absolument pas un temps productif
pour l'entreprise en même temps une
femme à qui on permet de remplir ses
objectifs personnels je peux vous
garantir que c'est une salarié hyper
motivée qui se sent très considéré et
qui se sent aussi très loyal vis-à-vis
de son entreprise
et puis sur vos parler aussi du risque
du cancer enfin du cancer du sein on
sait que l'allaitement c'est quand même
quelque chose qui est reconnu comme très
préventif
sortir du paradoxe et donner les moyens
d'occuper le rôle des dents ou de
soignants alors on peut aussi soyons
fous donner aux soignants les moyens de
soigner mais en tout cas
d'aider les aides familiales ou les
personnes qui ont ce rôle là dans la
famille de pouvoir mieux le faire et de
renforcer les politiques de congés en
forme malade et dans familial le
maintien de la mutuelle lors du congé
parental intégral sur le temps de
travail il existe des entreprises alors
les plus grosses sont les mieux lotis
mais qui proposent des tranches horaires
d'arrivée et de départ ce qui donne
beaucoup plus de souplesse dans
l'organisation
est-ce qu'on valorise la réalisation des
objectifs ou le nombre d'heures là aussi
c'est une vraie question comment est-ce
qu'on valorise ce qu'on appelle les
temps interstitiels c'est-à-dire en fait
les fausses posent il y a des milieux de
travail où la communication est
dysfonctionnelle où on n'a pas le temps
de se transmettre des informations et
ben finalement on va utiliser les pauses
pour faire ça alors certes c'est du coup
très chouette parce que ça va fédérer
les équipes ça va réguler des émotions
mais c'est pas des pauses voilà donc on
coupe pas avec le travail et on allait
pas sa charge cognitive
favoriser l'éducation émotionnelle
précoce pour tout le monde mieux repérer
et valider ses émotions mieux valoriser
les soins préventifs en général et les
soins psychiques en particulier de par
les efforts de remboursement
renforcer la présence des psychologues
dans les structures de soins à la fois
pour les patients mais aussi pour les
équipes pour les aider à réguler leur
tension
quid des contrôles arrêt maladie moi en
consultation j'ai un vrai problème avec
ça des personnes qui ne me demandent en
fait des attestations pour être sûr de
pouvoir
donner aux contrôleur sécu un papier qui
atteste qu'ils étaient pas en train de
se balader et encore j'ai envie de dire
même s'ils étaient en train de se
balader est-ce que c'est pas aussi la
possibilité d'avoir des expériences
positives pour sortir d'une dépression
ça c'est encore une vraie question
la prise en compte du genre dans
l'alliance thérapeutique ça aussi c'est
une question sans réponse est-ce que un
homme se confie plus facilement à un
homme sur un problème psychique ou
est-ce qu'il se confie plus facilement à
une femme et un versement
égalité rime avec équité et pas
indifférenciation on l'a assez dit la
question des retraites est-ce qu'on
récompense uniquement le temps qui est
générateur de richesse de richesse ou
est-ce qu'on peut aussi imaginer qu'on
pourrait récompenser les efforts de
cohésion sociale tout au long de la vie
les retraites aujourd'hui en tout cas
dans le débat qui qui nous concerne vont
impacter fortement les espaces de
transmission et d'entraide
intergénérationnelle que ce soit par
rapport à la gare des petits-enfants
mais aussi les soins aux parents une
femme de 65 ans a des parents qui sont
parfois très très dans une dépendance
très avancée et c'est souvent un point
crucial que de pouvoir leur apporter une
fin de vie digne dans un accompagnement
avec le sentiment d'avoir de rendre tout
ce qu'on a reçu de son parent et ça peut
être important
et enfin je me permets de clore là
dessus attention aux fausses bonnes
idées on sait qu'il y a déjà des
antécédents notamment dans
l'automatisation du travail le Voice
speaking où on pense alléger des choses
et en fait on crée de nouveaux problèmes
pareil pour les coupures dans le temps
de travail je termine là-dessus un
exemple
issu de ma pratique un petit supermarché
de province qui a vu ses risques
psychosociaux explosé à un moment donné
et suite à mon enquête en fait on s'est
rendu compte que c'est parce que on a
pour en voulant bien faire on a aboli
certaines coupures du Midi qui parfois
étaient très longues puisque c'était
quatre ou cinq heures
pardon sauf que du coup sur un métier
déjà peu valoriser ces 4 ou 5 heures de
coupure ça permettait le mercredi
d'économiser une garde d'enfant ça
permettait de passer du temps de les
accompagner au sport et ensuite de
revenir au travail et une fois qu'on
leur a enlevé ça cette capacité à
concilier une vie professionnelle et une
vie personnelle le seuil de tolérance à
d'autres difficultés comme les mauvais
rapport avec la chef KS ou la
polyvalence avec le fait de devoir aussi
aller
décharger des c'était plus toléré de la
même manière voilà je vous remercie
beaucoup oui
alors le Voice speaking alors oui non
mais vous faites alors c'est quelque
chose qui c'est mon jugement de valeur
ça me concerne que moi qui est très
déshumanisant en fait vous avez un
casque sur les oreilles et vous avez une
voix robotisée qui vous dit des numéros
toute la journée en fait qui vous dit
d'aller dans l'allée à prendre un
certain nombre de colis donc on vous dit
allez à deux et puis en fait vous vous
devez répondre en boucle ok pour montrer
que vous avez bien compris la consigne
et qu'ensuite vous avez fait ce qu'on
vous demandait de faire et donc toute la
journée vous entendez des chiffres et
vous répondez ok ok ok voilà et bon
c'est une façon de
transmettre des consignes qui te fait
gagner beaucoup de temps mais
merci beaucoup madame Chevassus pour
cette exposé très complet et donc je
vais me tourner vers la dernière
intervenante qui est Alice de Maximy
fondatrice du collectif femme de santé
premier collectif plus riche
professionnel de femmes qui ont une
activité dans le secteur de la santé qui
a récemment fait des propositions en
matière de santé des femmes au travail
dans ce secteur à vous madame je vous
remercie mesdames les sénatrices et
merci de me donner l'opportunité de
d'être la voix de ce collectif qui
compte 2700 membres
qu'on soit du secteur public ou du
secteur privé de la santé de l'industrie
ou qu'on soit aide-soignante on ne peut
parler avec une directrice de
laboratoire pharmaceutique quand on est
secrétaire médicale dans ce collectif
c'est important pour nous on a 50 hommes
dans le collectif qui est ouvert aux
hommes parce qu'on ne rétablit pas une
égalité de genre en en créant une autre
et la genèse du collectif c'est un
rapport du CSA qui a épinglé la santé
qui est présente les femmes uniquement
comme mère d'enfants malades
pas des postes d'experts et c'est tout à
fait la jeunesse du collectif le
collectif il a comme mission de se
construire un système de santé plus
juste plus équitable et plus égalitaire
et de faire avancer à santé par
l'intelligence collective
pluridisciplinaire
grâce à la sororité j'ajoute qu'en tant
qu'actrice de santé publique à l'origine
pendant plus de 15 ans voire 20
et maintenant startupeuse un tel
collectif n'existe pas la santé elle est
cloisonnée au niveau du secteur public
et du secteur privé qui se déteste il
faut être franche parce que c'est la
vérité et de l'autre elle est cloisonnée
à cause d'une hiérarchie sclérosante qui
pèse aussi sur les conditions de travail
de tous et notamment des femmes et elle
est aussi cloisonnée par les secteurs
d'activité tant le chant est large et
donc c'est le seul collectif qui a
explosé ses cloisons là du coup
l'approche que je vais avoir va pas du
tout être celle que vous avez eu jusqu'à
maintenant puisqu'on décloisonne
systématiquement et on dézoome
systématiquement dans ce collectif
il est porté donc par la startup hkind
il n'a pas un statut associatif mais ces
orientations stratégiques éthiques
opérationnelles sont toutes discutées en
comité d'organisation qui regroupe des
femmes de santé de tous les secteurs et
un système de sondage en ligne permet de
définir les thématiques de nos travaux
donc en fait ça fonctionne de manière
plutôt démocratique
avant d'aborder le point fort c'est à
dire les travaux du collectif chouette à
retirer votre attention sur deux enjeux
de santé au travail que j'ai pu
percevoir ou qui m'ont été reportés par
les membres du collectif donc là je ne
fais pas un écho de travaux basés sur
des faits mais sur des des témoignages
qui ont pu remonter les femmes victimes
de violences intrafamiliales
représenteraient 10% des salariés et es
et les repérer et les aider au travail
est en faveur de leur santé mentale
les hôpitaux est une obligation de faire
des plans d'égalité un des hôpital a
créé tout un système d'accueil des
femmes victimes de violence salariés et
a permis de le remettre dans dans
l'emploi alors qu'elles étaient tout en
arrêt maladie
les remarques sexistes n'ont toujours
dans ce volet là les remarques sexistes
dans le secteur de la santé sont légion
maintenant avec la nouvelle loi beaucoup
d'entre elles sont considérées comme du
harcèlement c'est extrêmement fréquent
et c'est dû aussi à une cloisonnement au
niveau de l'ariérarchie de qui commande
dans ce secteur là c'est à dire que
notamment dans le public les directeurs
d'hôpitaux ne sont entre guillemets par
nous le dire aussi crûment pas des chefs
des médecins et des pôles soignants du
coup c'est un peu compliqué c'est un peu
le système de l'éducation nationale pour
les collèges
des patrons sont pas les directeurs
d'hôpitaux donc du coup ça crée vraiment
des vrais enjeux ou quand ils veulent
installer une politique claire soit en
santé soit en RH ils peuvent pas s'y la
CME ne passe pas ne passe pas et pas une
volonté des soignants dessus donc ça
c'était pour le premier point un peu
pour faire un volet sur sur ce qui se
passe et puis le deuxième c'est c'est
pas de chez nous mais je me fais écho et
si vous les auditionnez je me tais tout
de suite je peux pas vous donner le
document puisqu'il m'a été donné de
façon non-officielle enfin officielle
mais non diffusable la MNH la fondation
de la MNH
la Mutuelle Nationale des Hospitaliers a
fait une revue de la littérature
internationale sur justement ce qui se
passait de la santé et de la femme dans
le secteur professionnel de la santé
donc la santé des professionnels de
santé il ressort effectivement qu'il y a
d'énormes enjeux de santé reproductif et
sexuelle des problèmes de la grossesse
les problèmes de la grossesse ils sont
dû effectivement un taux de fausse
couche supérieur à la moyenne mais il y
a un autre enjeu aussi qui ressort c'est
qu'en fait comme on a du mal à recruter
des soignants dans le secteur
hospitalier privé ou public l'annonce
d'une grossesse est un vrai problème
puisque le poste n'est pas remplacé donc
vous imaginez bien que du coup les
conséquences et là je vous parle de
statistiques pour le coup pas de choses
qui m'ont reporter sans que par exemple
les femmes internes ne font pas
d'enfants puisque leur stage est reporté
donc elle perdent en ancienneté et elle
travaille vraiment à un poste plus tard
et même les femmes reculent leur moment
de maternité voire ne font pas d'enfants
donc c'est un point important parce que
et c'est dû aussi c'est vrai une
perception de ce qui est fait d'avoir un
enfant mais c'est surtout dû au fait que
comme les postes ne sont pas remplacés
une personne qui part en congé maternité
ça crée un trouble dans le service qui
est déjà hyper tendu
voilà donc ça je vous invite vraiment à
je peux demander à vous fournir cette
étude de la MNH je pense qu'il est
extrêmement intéressant parce qu'elle a
été faite au niveau international elle
montre vraiment ce qui se passe là où il
y a un gap dans ce genre d'études c'est
dans toutes les études qui ont été
faites c'est qu'on a complètement oublié
les aides-soignantes
et l'autre endroit où il y a un gap
c'est qu'on oublie toujours parce
qu'elles ne sont pas des employés à
proprement dit de l'hôpital mais
qu'elles sont payées par des
prestataires de services en contrat ce
sont les femmes qui apportent les
plateaux et qui font le ménage à
l'hôpital et elle elles ont des
conditions de travail déplorable mais on
en parle jamais et leur profession est
au moins à 95% féminine donc juste
j'attire votre attention on a 0 donné
là-dessus
alors un petit préambule avant de parler
des travaux on parle beaucoup de
discrimination
on parle de discrimination positive
juste pour rappeler qu'en anglais on
parle d'affin d'affirmative action c'est
pas du tout la même perception la
discrimination positive le terme
discrimination serait peut-être à
enlever de ce point là en santé on parle
d'équité pour plein de raisons et ça
c'est acté en tout cas par tous les
personnes qui œuvrent dans la santé et
qui travaillent sur la santé de la femme
en décembre dernier on a organisé des
États généraux des femmes de santé où il
y avait plusieurs centaines de personnes
les États généraux chez nous ont comme
objectif de trouver des solutions utiles
pratiques et concrètes à de grands
enjeux de santé et cette année le thème
choisi était la santé de la femme
l'année dernière je ne résiste pas au
fait de vous le dire c'était la place de
la femme dans le secteur professionnel
de la santé vous imaginez qu'on a trouvé
énormément de solutions qu'on a
identifié énormément d'enjeux je vous en
parle quand vous voulez
un petit rappel méthodologique sur ces
états généraux d'abord on fait une revue
de la littérature grise française c'est
à dire les études qui sont qui ont été
publiées qu'on peut trouver en ligne
on en extrait les problématiques qui
existent on les présente aux femmes de
santé et les femmes de santé
identifiées avec nous des grands enjeux
sur lesquels elles veulent travailler
qui répondent au panorama qu'on leur a
fait à cette synthèse de la revue de la
littérature 14 ateliers collaboratifs
ont été créés l'événement a eu lieu le 9
décembre 30 solutions ont été proposées
et données au cabinet ministériel de la
santé de l'égalité de la fonction
publique et une lettre ouverte au
pouvoir public signé par 700 personnes a
été écrite pour créer un institut
national santé de la femme qui serait
publique privée à but non lucratif on
est en train de s'accrocher pour trouver
la structure juridique qu'il porte qui
aurait comme objectif de porter une
stratégie nationale santé de la femme
qui n'existe pas
et ça nous a paru absolument incroyable
que ça n'existe pas
à noter aussi il n'existe pas de
parcours de santé de la femme en dehors
de la maternité du cancer du col et du
cancer du sein il y en a pas on parle de
parcours de santé de parcours de santé
c'est la prévention le soin le poste
soin c'est l'ensemble de ce qui concerne
la santé de la femme alors on l'a
travaillé ce le jour des États généraux
je vous en parlerai une autre fois
éventuellement mais à titre d'exemple
concrets saviez-vous que les petites
filles sont traitées plusieurs années
après les petits garçons quand elles ont
un retard de croissance
de croissance
et on sait qu'il est important de donner
hormones croissant son beau moment ça
c'est un exemple tout à fait concret de
ce qui se passe actuellement à la santé
on n'avait pas du tout du tout du tout
perçu ça avant de faire cette étude de
la revue de la littérature pas du tout
on avait des échos et les femmes de
santé nous demander de travailler dessus
et on s'était pas posé la question du
tout et on a découvert qu'il y avait
tellement de trous dans la raquette il y
avait tellement d'inégalités il y avait
tellement de choses qui n'avaient pas
été faites qu'on n'a pas été capable de
dire mais sur quel sujet on va
travailler et du coup on a organisé un
atelier qui avait comme objectif de
réfléchir à quel sujet on allait
travailler dans ces états généraux
le thème des États généraux précis et
inégalités de santé chez les femmes
brisées les paradigmes mais proposer une
approche positive vous allez comprendre
pourquoi très vite ce qui est ressorti
de cette synthèse que je peux vous
envoyer
c'est que si on n'a pas compris que tout
tourne autour de la charge mentale des
femmes du sexisme intégré des tabous et
des biaisés alors on n'a pas du tout
compris ce qui se passe dans la santé de
la femme
et c'est ça qu'on a identifié et on a pu
démontrer par les études que la charge
mentale est responsable 1 de l'accès aux
soins et de l'accès à la prévention or
si on parle de prévention des
préventions tous qu'on propose je viens
de PES juste pour préciser donc je suis
une fan de prévention et pendant des
années je me suis moi la première fois
voyez tout ce que nous proposons en
prévention notamment pour les femmes
alourdies la charge mentale donc elles
ne vont pas dans la prévention puisqu'on
leur propose une prévention qui est à
l'origine alourdine à charge mentale et
donc on tourne en rond en fait dans ce
circuit de prévention et c'est ça qu'on
a découvert on a découvert ça pourquoi
parce qu'il y a ne serait-ce que trois
ans même si de 85 l'idée on parlait à
peine de charge mentale encore moins de
charge mentale dite médicale maintenant
qui est en gros que la femme si elle a
une famille va penser au rendez-vous de
tout le monde sauf des siens et donc
elle va pas aller faire ses dépistage et
autres d'autant plus qu'en plus derrière
on parle de si sont dépistage est
positif et qu'elle a un cancer on va
parler de cancer évitable car vous
pouvez dépister tôt vous imaginez quoi
de la culpabilité des femmes d'avoir un
cancer évitable parce qu'elle est pas
allé se faire des petites stats à temps
donc voilà donc ça c'est juste un peu
qui se passe un peu dans et c'est ce
qu'on a trouvé donc je vais avancer un
peu les freins donc à cette prise en
charge en fait d'être bien soigné ou de
prendre soin de sa santé sont en
deuxième exposition à charge mentale en
première l'argent
l'argent et on sait que les femmes sont
plus précaires etc etc donc je reviens
pas sur ces démonstrations là donc ce
sont les deux points on s'est retrouvé
face à ça avec cette notion de tabou qui
revenait toujours en fond toujours et
encore avec cette notion de banalisation
des symptômes avec cette notion de
maladie totalement inconnue de tous avec
cette notion de maladie mixte mais qui
ont des spécificités féminines on s'est
dit mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce
qu'on fait de ça on a décidé de
travailler en amont des États généraux
sur deux grands ateliers faire en sorte
que les préventions les préventions
primaires secondaires et tertiaires ne
soient pas perçue comme des contraintes
supplémentaires mais un moyen de lever
la charge mentale des femmes quelque
chose qui n'a jamais été fait dans la
santé jamais été pensé comme ça on s'est
dit objectivement on va dire voilà on
entre femmes qu'on était un peu folle de
partir là dessus qu'on n'y arriverait
jamais et pourtant on l'a fait et le
deuxième point c'est la littératie en
santé ou comment donner la bonne info le
bon choix au bon moment d'autres termes
comment les tabous autour de la femme la
charge mentale et je vais en venir à
l'enjeu du travail
30 solutions donc et je vais vous en
citer quelques-unes en préalable juste
la charge mentale la grande confusion
entre la charge mentale et la santé
mentale on l'a eu on l'a eu pour plein
de raisons et donc on parlait parfois de
santé mentale parfois de chargementale
les deux sont intimement liés en fait et
covid pour ne pas le citer puisque vous
nous posez la question à démontrer et on
le sait et à alourdit en fait à alourdi
la charge mentale des femmes mais a
aussi indirectement puisqu'on a vu déjà
dans les dans les les discours tout à
l'heure qu'il y avait une une différence
entre les hommes et les femmes qui a été
montré dans une étude notamment une
étude Suisse que on n'avait pas du tout
la même façon de percevoir
nos risques le traitement et
l'interprétation du stress n'est pas la
même là je parle d'études voilà les
convictions de pouvoir maîtriser son
son existence elle est moins marquée
cette conviction chez les femmes
et en plus on ajoute à ça de plus faible
revenu donc c'est compliqué plus pour
les femmes que pour les hommes c'est
comme ça et la perte de l'identité du
rôle sexuel on en parle trop peu
l'infertilité la ménopause les
expériences d'avortement tout ça font
que en fait on a plus de vulnérabilités
à ce niveau là et donc si on ajoute à ça
la charge mentale et ben là on passe du
côté santé mentale donc c'est toute cet
enjeu donc on ne peut pas faire fille de
la charge mentale en santé publique en
fait mais jusqu'à présent rien rien rien
n'a été pris en compte en santé publique
dans les dispositifs de prévention
concernant la charge mentale à part sans
doute pour la médecine travail où vous
en tenez compte mais dans le quotidien
et dans l'ensemble des politiques
publiques la charge mentale elle passe à
lasse il n'y a pas un seul indicateur de
charge mentale dans tous les dispositifs
qu'on propose
du coup on a fait plusieurs
recommandations je vous cite au niveau
de la charge mentale recommenciation qui
concerne les employeurs donc nous allons
dans le milieu de travail et je vais
parler et pardon la médecine du travail
donc je suis très heureuse de vous
rencontrer mesdames parce qu'on a des
choses à discuter
nous proposons que les préventions
soient mises en place sur le temps de
travail voire organisé par les
employeurs
et tous les employeurs qui ont été aux
États généraux étaient d'accord et
certains le font déjà certains ont une
journée de congés dédiée à la prévention
voilà comme ça au moins c'est clair
c'est cadré en d'autres termes
d’accorder du temps de santé prévention
Adam les accords des salariés et faire
venir et faire venir les préventions aux
femmes donc soit on accorde une journée
soit on prend les rendez-vous parfois
les femmes ne veulent pas c'est pas
toujours si simple soit on fait venir
des gens sur un lieu de travail pour
faire des campagnes de vaccination par
exemple donc ça c'est un des points
qu'on a qu'on a mis en place au même
titre qu'il existe des référents égalité
il faudrait des référents prévention
voilà dans les entreprises donc on a
réussi à le faire pour l'égalité on
pourrait très bien le faire pour la
santé là on s'est focusé santé de la
femme certes vous vous doutez bien que
ce genre de proposition son mixte bien
sûr et bénéficie à tous
la prévention des récidives après une
longue maladie et après un congé
maternité compliqué est aussi une des
demandes que l'on a faite pour les
employeurs qu'il y ait quelque chose
vraiment de demander et de mis en place
dans ce cadre-là un retour de maternité
compliqué c'est compliqué et c'est sur
le dos de la femme voilà ça c'est dans
les statistiques c'est même pas une
question d'opinion
afin d'inciter les employeurs à tenir
compte de la singularité féminine dans
la santé là il y a tout un levier qui
est complexe
un employeur qui parle de la santé des
femmes c'est tellement tabou que les
femmes qui prônent l'égalité ne veulent
parfois pas en entendre parler
et en même temps il le faut parce qu'il
y a une singularité de la femme dans la
santé et c'est tout cette ambiguïté
autour de la parole qu'on met dans les
entreprises avec le rôle de l'employeur
qui doit être travaillé discuter et pour
lequel on a un besoin vraiment de
coopération
en ce qui concerne des demandes que nous
avions en direction des pouvoirs publics
en pensant que c'était plutôt de l'ordre
des pouvoirs publics il est nécessaire
de mettre en place une macro-étue une
macro étude économique qui montre le
bénéfice des préventions au sein de
l'entreprise par rapport au fait de pas
le faire avec une entreprise pilote
il y a un moment il faut quand même
regarder chose en face on va pas dans la
prévention quand on est employeur parce
qu'on a peur que ça coûte de l'argent
sauf qu'en fait le bénéfice il est réel
on le sait on en entend parler tout le
monde le dit sauf qu'il y a jamais eu
une Neptune économique qui la trouve
qu'il a trouvé il y a les moyens on a la
méthode on sait faire les études
macroéconomiques faut juste les mettre
en place une fois qu'on a montré que
c'est efficace et que c'est une économie
que pour l'entreprise déjà on a un
argument
qui contre la performance cet argument
qui est en remonté pour dire mais vous
vous trompez ensuite
clarifier le rôle et les missions de la
médecine du travail mériterait d'être
mis en place on sait qu'il y a des
guerres entre les entre les groupes de
médecine disons le clairement et il y a
notamment vous le savez les trois
rendez-vous de prévention qui ne sont
pas des consultations qui sont des
rendez-vous de prévention qui peuvent
donner lieu à une consultation quel est
le rôle de la médecine de travail dans
ces trois rendez-vous de prévention on
sait que pour l'instant les moyens pour
les mettre en oeuvre il y a déjà les
médecins sont déjà noyés les gens sur le
terrain sont déjà noyés quel est le rôle
de la médecine de la prévention
là-dessus la médecine du travail pardon
c'est un lapsus mais elles auraient son
jeu à jouer et puis on parle beaucoup de
la femme au travail on a oublié ici on y
a pensé les femmes qui ne travaillent
pas
les failles qui ne travaillent pas et
ben elles vont pas non plus dans la
santé elles y vont pas parce que du coup
elles peuvent pas y aller parce qu'en
général si elle travaille pas c'est
qu'elle s'occupe de leurs enfants et que
quand elles ont des rendez-vous
prévention elles n'y vont pas non plus
et donc il serait bien mais que la CAF
organise un système pour qu'elle puisse
aller faire leurs examens quand elles
doivent le faire
on les oublie souvent enfin
on demande que dans toutes les
politiques publiques
dans toutes les politiques de prévention
il y a un indicateur charge mentale
c'est-à-dire que quand on pense un
système de prévention quand on pense une
campagne de prévention quand on pense à
un dispositif de prévention on pense
l'indicateur charge mentale qu'est-ce
qu'on fait est-ce que ce que je propose
encore à grandir la charge mentale ou
pas et si oui bah ça veut dire que je
vais proposer quelque chose avec
énormément de trous dans la raquette et
qu'une bonne partie des familles iront
pas dans cette prévention
le deuxième atelier j'en ai fini avec
ces recommandations là et après je vais
juste rebondir sur la lettre ouverte et
après j'en aurai fini
on demande pour libérer ses tabous la
bonne information au bon moment pour le
bon choix on sait maintenant que la
plupart des femmes qui ont un cancer
comprennent absolument rien leur maladie
et que celles qui ont un traitement
comprennent pas leur traitement et on
sait aussi que aucun médecin quasiment
ça c'est des rapports des femmes de
santé alors effectivement je suis
caricaturale c'est pas aucune et c'est
pas très peu mais beaucoup et les
associations de patientes reçoivent des
patientes qui ne comprennent pas leur
maladie on va dire comme ça c'est plus
c'est plus juste
on ne leur pose pas la question dans le
cadre du soin qu'avez-vous compris de
votre maladie on ne leur pose pas la
question dans le cadre du soin
qu'avez-vous pour penser de votre
retraitement donc la reformulation n'est
pas proposée j'insiste là-dessus
c'était juste une parenthèse sur la
santé de la femme ce qu'on propose nous
donc c'est pas dans ce cadre ça c'est
dans ce cadre là mais c'est pas dans le
travail c'est qui est une campagne de
communication pour faire pour prendre
conscience à toutes et à tous de ce que
sont les tabous autour de la santé de la
femme pour pouvoir les libérer dans le
travail
pour pouvoir les libérer dans le cadre
des soins et pour pouvoir les libérer
pour les hommes
donc dans ce cadre là la libération des
tabous on la souhaite Pioneer chez les
femmes et ce serait une campagne de
communication qui montrerait des
symptômes tabous chez les femmes qui en
parlent entre elles et qui dirait ben
non c'est pas normal en d'autres termes
j'ai fait j'ai un déterminer je viens de
me faire pipi dessus c'est normal dans
la famille tout le monde se pisse dessus
bah non c'est pas normal voilà ça c'est
un exemple de tabou le moins le plus
facile à dire et je n'évoquerai pas les
autres pour finir cette lettre ouverte
qui souhaite une stratégie nationale
dans cette stratégie nationale doivent
participer l'ensemble des acteurs de la
société on a tendance et ça c'est une
demande des femmes de santé à dire que
quand on travaille de la santé on va
inviter des associations de patients
déjà c'est mieux qu'avant
on va inviter les autorités de santé on
va inviter des soignants mais on va
zapper complètement et définitivement
les employeurs mais même des employeurs
qui ne sont pas du secteur des
employeurs de l'industrie des employeurs
de la de n'importe quel secteur de la
santé de l'annonce santé ils doivent
être parti prenantes dans une stratégie
nationale santé de la femme pourquoi
parce que les femmes représentent 50% de
la population parce que la manifeste la
banalisation des manifestations
cliniques demeure parce que les biais
genre et prise en charge dans les prises
en charge demeure parce que la charge
mentale pèse sur les femmes parce qu'on
s'est désormais que les maladies mixtes
ne s'expriment pas de la même façon chez
les deux
parce que beaucoup de femmes dans leurs
paroles ne sont pas entendues et leurs
paroles complètement minorée parce que
les errances diagnostiques sont trop
nombreuses parce que la recherche
épidémiaux les données récoltées les
essais cliniques ne sont pas enrés on
l'a vu sur d'autres secteurs on l'a vu
dans le cadre de la de la santé au
travail mais ce n'est pas que là-dedans
enfin des recherches épidémies sont pas
genre quand même dans la plupart des cas
on les a les statistiques et de dire que
c'est compliqué de gens ré on a les
stats ou alors maintenant on peut juste
demander une croix de genre dans
l'ensemble des questionnaires qu'on fait
c'est pas insurmontable les spécialistes
de la santé de la femme sont aussi trop
peu nombreux les tabous on l'a vu
demeure on sait désormais aussi que
l'ensemble de ces points là sont
essentiels les biaisen réinconscients
dans tous les secteurs professionnels
sont présents
la caricature des femmes est présente la
recherche de la santé de la femme prise
dans sa globalité n'existe pas et n'a
jamais été abordé
on plane complet en fait et c'est ce
dont on se sont aperçus l'ensemble des
femmes de santé et quand je parle des
femmes de santé je parle de toutes les
femmes qu'elles soient avocats de la
santé start-upeuse professeur des
universités chercheuses médecins de
terrain
infirmière en libéral peu importe on
sait tout rendu compte lors de ses états
généraux qu'en fait on n'avait pas pensé
à une santé de la femme
il n'y a pas de programme national santé
de la femme et si on salue le programme
la stratégie nationale endométriose elle
est thématisée il y a énormément
d'autres symptômes féminins qui sont
complètement abandonnés laissés de côté
et ignorer il n'y a pas que
l'endométriose il n'y a pas que des
symptômes de la sphère gynécologique la
première cause de mortalité chez les
femmes c'est les accidents vasculaires
cérébraux je vous remercie j'ai été un
peu longue mais j'insiste vraiment sur
le fait que tous doivent être inclus
quand on parle de la santé des femmes y
compris les employeurs qui ne viennent
pas du secteur de la santé je vous
remercie
et bien écoutez merci mesdames pour
cette exposée à 5 voix les rapporteurs
vont peut-être avoir des questions très
très courtes que les interventions
étaient extrêmement complètes et étayé
donc parce que on a une séance à 10h30
qui va reprendre dans l'hémicycle pour
laquelle certains
interviennent dans la discussion
générale et donc peut-être que s'il y a
des questions vous les posez et de toute
façon on gardera contact et on prendra
connaissance des éléments que vous
souhaiterez nous apporter en complément
alors d'abord Laurence Cohen on va je
vais prendre toutes les questions et
puis comme ça si on manque de temps vous
n'hésiterez pas à revenir vers nous
Laurence Cohen un porteur oui moi je
vous remercie mesdames parce que j'ai
trouvé chacune de vos interventions
extrêmement riches et et complète et
nous incitant finalement à
réfléchir à pousser davantage et puis il
y aurait plein de questions à vous poser
à chacune mais je vais j'ai vraiment
être très brève parce que effectivement
je vais partir dans pas longtemps en
fait moi je je
j'ai un petit souci c'est que au niveau
d'une manière générale au niveau des
entreprises et surtout au niveau de la
santé au travail il y a quand même un
manque criant de médecin du travail la
médecine du travail a été
particulièrement mise à mal ces
dernières années et donc il y a très peu
de moyens et tout ce que vous nous avez
rapporté qu'en tout cas moi je partage
nécessite des moyens humains et des
moyens financiers donc que ce soit en
termes de médecin de psychologue etc
c'est extrêmement appauvri donc je me
dis que il y a peut-être déjà ça à
prendre en compte pour pouvoir aussi
intervenir de manière plus efficace
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez c'est tout
question merci Madame la rapporteur je
passe la parole la rapporteur Laurence
Rossignol parce que j'ai vu qu'elle
était dans les premiers internationaux
non on le souhaite pas parce qu'elle est
dans les premiers intervenants dans la
discussion générale voilà donc
la rapporteur Marie-Pierre Richer alors
je vais poser juste une question aussi
moi ça va concerner par rapport à vos à
vos interventions je vous en remercie
d'ailleurs parce qu'on s'interrogeait
encore sur la nécessité de conduire nos
travaux sur santé des femmes et travail
et vos interventions ont montré que
cette cela prenait tout son sens je
crois que c'est assez évident moi je
vais juste revenir sur le sur le
document unique d'évaluation des risques
professionnels parce que je me disais on
vous écoutant que après tout dans la
santé au travail
la simple travail passe aussi par ce
document et que sa mise en oeuvre dans
les entreprises fait souvent des fours
rencontre de réels difficultés ça a été
soulevé tout à l'heure par une une de
vous concernant notamment la crainte du
préventeur d'accroître le risque de
discrimination on sait aussi que c'est
une sous-estimation dans les politiques
publiques de l'enjeu que représente la
ségularité homme-femme dans l'évaluation
des risques professionnel personnel et
justement madame par rapport à votre
dernier intervention je me demandais si
par le prisme de de la charge la charge
mentale on ne pouvait pas arriver et
bien l'inclure sans que ce soit
discriminatoire
alors c'est une question qu'on se pose à
chaque fois puisque on est pour une pour
une égalité de genre et donc c'était
pour moi en on est d'accord
pardon
non non mais du coup il y a pas d'autres
questions au niveau des rapports si la
rapporteur rossignol
moi d'abord merci pour la qualité de vos
interventions comme Marie-Pierre Richet
je effectivement on a on a effectivement
on commence à asserner notre sujet de
rapport sur femme et travail en sachant
que vous avez quand même tout aussi fait
remarquer que on manquait
d'intérêt
scientifique universitaire d'études
pour arriver à bien sur des sujets ce
que j'ai entendu beaucoup dans vos
interventions c'est qu'en fait on dit
toujours le privé et politique j'ai
envie de dire le privé professionnelle
l'interaction entre
la charge mentale
la double journée est très forte en fait
sur les conditions psychologiques et
physiologique d'ailleurs aussi des
femmes au travail donc mon interrogation
est plus technique en fait c'est comment
on arrive à
identifier cette question de la charge
mentale non pas d'un point de vue
psychologique on approche on la comprend
empiriquement mais comment on arrive en
en faire un objet suffisamment clair et
utilisable voilà la charge mentale elle
se elle soit pose canner c'est ça le
sujet pour la faire rentrer dans le
débat politique et social en fait voilà
c'est merci beaucoup la rapporteur et en
dernière intervention de victoire jasmin
ce sera un coup alors je voudrais qu'on
est vraiment à prendre en compte
également les femmes de la police parce
que nous avons rencontré des femmes de
la police qui subissent vraiment des
charges émotionnelles très fortes qui
ont des tenues très lourdes et qui sont
victimes dans d'autres métiers comme
toutes les femmes en fait quelquefois et
quand elles ont leurs règles quelquefois
également et non pas de possibilités
d'aller se changer parce qu'elles sont
dans les voitures pendant toute la
journée et c'est compliqué
et puis les femmes qui travaillent dans
les laboratoires une chirurgie médicale
et d'un impact qui sont confrontés aux
problèmes du formol et de réactifs de
biochimie voilà je ne dis pas alors même
la présidente est-ce qu'on a prévu
l'INRS dans les auditions ce serait
intéressant c'est prévu d'accord ok
merci merci Madame jasmin pour cette
vigilance de toute épreuve alors je vais
vous laisser vous organiser pour des
réponses courtes et si vous voulez les
compléter
ultérieurement par mail auprès de de
l'administration du Sénat on en prendra
connaissance bien entendu merci donc je
donne la parole à qui peut-être
madame
anne-michel Chartier d'abord
et celle qui ne souhaitent pas répondre
lève la main comme ça je pense je fais
le tour de table rapidement voilà le
problème abordé c'est le manque de
médecin du travail le manque du médecin
du travail effectivement pas tant mais
c'est un manque de médecin en général et
partout et il y a eu les services de
santé ont été élargies avec les
psychologues avec les infirmiers avec
des assistances en thé au travail donc
par rapport aux actions de prévention
des actions de prévention primaires en
milieu de travail il y a autre chose que
le médecin qui peut intervenir et les
campagnes de prévention dans les
entreprises au sein des entreprises sont
faits par les infirmières les campagnes
les le travail sur les risques
psychosociaux en prévention primaire
dans le der peut être fait par la
psychologue du travail c'est des choses
que l'on délègue à ces personnes mais
effectivement en santé il reste des
situations faire reprendre et
identifier dans la reprise du travail
dans le maintien dans l'emploi c'est
vrai qu'un regard médical est nécessaire
pour travailler sur telle personne à tel
moi en fonction de sa pathologie en
particulier le du RP c'est un élément
pour nous essentiel parce que c'est les
conditions de travail et la charge
mentale elle doit être travaillée à
travers le DRP qui va travailler sur les
risques organisationnels donc le risque
organisationnel c'est les 6 axes de
rapports
donc on va explorer la charge la charge
de travail on va explorer les conflits
d'éthique on va explorer les l'autonomie
et tout ça c'est pas si compliqué que ça
parce que les conflits d'éthique on peut
très bien les énumérer dans un EHPAD sur
les problèmes de toilette c'est quelque
chose qui est facile à aborder et sur
lequel on doit avoir des réponses donc
ça c'est la charge mentale à travers
cette évaluation des six axes elle est
tout à fait faisable mais il faut
qu'elle soit toute qu'elle soit intégrée
et qu'elle soit
de fait systématique mais c'est pas
seulement les femmes c'est aussi les
hommes on n'a pas tous les en séance et
sinon
la cuvée c'était est aussi la façon de
d'introduire ces problèmes de charge
mentale et ses problèmes de qualité de
vie au travail et la qualité des
conditions de travail a été la loi a
changé c'est plus QVT c'est QVC qualité
des conditions de travail et il y a un
travail par exemple sur les EHPAD de la
rate
Île-de-France sur la qualité de vie au
travail dans les EHPAD pour les
personnels et ça c'est des choses qui
font intervenir le chargemental la
charge mentale la charge la souffrance
le contact avec la souffrance qui fait
partie de la charge mentale
merci beaucoup deuxième réponse merci
pour la rapidité et la concision
également alors sur le point 1 je vais
juste me permettre de rajouter un petit
exemple en fait sur le manque de médecin
dans les Bouches-du-Rhône enfin de
manière générale au niveau national il
existe un dispositif qui permet de
renforcer les équipes de médecins du
travail ce qui est le dispositif du
médecin collaborateur qui est en fait
une possibilité de passerelle de médecin
traitant enfin le médecin généraliste à
médecin du travail c'est un une
formation supplémentaire qui implique
quatre années à titre d'exemple dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône il y a quatre places à
l'université sachant qu'on a des besoins
d'un médecin qui sont criants donc voilà
il y a peut-être un petit sujet là sur
le point du DIU je pense que l'ensemble
des services santé au travail
développent des efforts pour accompagner
les entreprises et mieux les informer
mieux les outiller sur la la tenue et la
mise à jour de leur desurp sur
l'identification de la charge mentale
comme un objet clair et partager
définissable je pense qu'on peut
peut-être s'inspirer de ce qui est fait
sur la définition du harcèlement qui est
difficile finalement à qualifier en
termes de fait précis reprochable par
contre on a une définition qui est
tournée sur les conséquences que ça sur
la victime et peut-être qu'on peut
s'inspirer de ça pour définir la charge
mentale c'est-à-dire finalement
qu'est-ce qui va opérer une charge
mentale est-ce que c'est tant de
sollicitations par jour ou est-ce que
c'est chez la personne qui en est qui
est concernée la nécessité de faire face
à différentes obligations de se sentir
désorganisé de se sentir dans
l'obligation de répondre à différentes
demandes de contradictoires voilà on
peut peut-être s'inspirer de ça et j'en
termine sur les femmes dans la police je
partage entièrement ce que vous venez de
dire mais ayant travaillé presque 10 ans
dans la police nationale et en tout cas
voilà j'ai une bonne pensée pour elle
pas grand chose à rajouter du coup de
plus effectivement en manque de moyenne
de moyens de médecins effectivement il y
a mes cinq collaborateurs qui nous qui
nous rejoignent maintenant on a on
travaille beaucoup avec les infirmiers
quand même majorité des visites sont
faits par eux et l'évaluation de tout ce
qu'on se parle là ça demande aussi une
formation pour les infirmiers voilà et
qui est voilà leur transformation de
métier est pas très simple donc du coup
effectivement je pense qu'il va falloir
quelques années quand même pour que tout
ça se mette en place
après sur l'évaluation de la charge
mentale oui c'est sûr qu'on peut le voir
sur le l'angle du prisme de la réduction
des facteurs de risque psychosocial il y
a aussi la charge mentale qu'on a à
titre personnel voilà et qui est aussi
une évaluation un peu individuelle puis
après il y a toutes celles qui sont
liées au process de travail aussi qui
sont quand même difficile à évaluer
alors moi je vous donnerai juste la
définition qu'à trouver le docteur
Catherine Azoulay chez nous justement
dans ses travaux charges mentale santé
mentale c'est Aurélia Schneider qui est
psychiatre qui précise que et qui a été
la première à le mettre en place la
charge mentale a été définie pour la
première fois 44 donc
la psychiatre le raconte par la
sociologue Monique Eco comme le fait de
penser simultanément à des choses
appartenant à deux mondes séparés
physiquement
exemple la mère au travail qui pense à
ce qu'elle doit faire en rentrant le
soir à la maison elle génère donc une
sollicitation constante des pensées et
des émotions d'une personne du fait de
la planification de la gestion et
l'exécution d'une tâche ou d'un ensemble
de tâches elle peut atteindre tout le
monde dans tous les domaines de la vie
professionnelle familial personnel
domestique et parental sans aucunement
se limiter à la double journée des Mères
voilà la charge mentale telle qu'elle
est définie dans ce dans ce par cette
sociologue là qui a été la première à la
mettre sur le tapis
merci beaucoup et donc pour par souci
d'égalité madame qui est en visio madame
Rollin qui est en visio à ce qu'elle
souhaitait apporter une un complément
rapide à ces interventions sur les
questions des rapporteurs
merci beaucoup pour
être intéressant
juste ajouter
[Musique]
des équipes publicitaires mais c'est
aussi une opportunité puisque les
entretiens infirmiers on a bien monté au
travers de différentes dispositifs et
notamment de Paris Ouest que ce qui est
dit à une infirmière pendant salarié
n'était pas la même chose que c'était
dit à un médecin et c'est important
parce que du coup les confrontations
entre les différentes professionnelles
que ce soit les psychologues dans la
liste d'exemples ce matin et bien c'est
aussi une richesse de notre de nos
équipes d'être en pluridisciplinarité et
voilà et si le manque de médecin est
important et bien ça nous a apporté
aussi cette opportunité de travailler
avec différents États mais c'est
important de santé au travail merci
beaucoup
merci beaucoup à vous mesdames pour
cette ces présentations extrêmement
complète que vous nous avez apportées
les éléments aussi des PowerPoint qui
était tout à fait précis et qui vont
éclairer le travaux les travaux des
quatre rapporteurs donc la réunion se
termine un peu on va dire un peu en
queue de poisson mais en fait vous a
laissé beaucoup de temps dans la
présentation et c'est aussi ce qui était
très enrichissant ce matin donc merci
vraiment pour tous ces réponses et
n'hésitez pas évidemment à compléter ces
réponses et vous le souhaitez par des
références auxquelles vous avez pu faire
et puis par pour compléter les questions
déjà posées et nous allons rejoindre la
séance puisque c'est un texte qui
concerne un petit peu la délégation au
droit des femmes il est question des
parcours de sortie et d'aide économique
pour les femmes ce qui subissent les
violences donc c'est le vote final et
c'était important pour nos collègues
d'être présentes puisqu'en plus elles
belle journée à toutes et à tous merci